fun fact this shows still brought to the
cash out what yeah you don't say still
then everyone finance app on the App
Store and the easiest way to since pin
save money ah Cash Shop is so easy to
use they're confident that we can
explain who they are and what they do
without saying any of the following
words like the game taboo alright Benton
ready yeah you can't say money dollar
app phone by split pace and receive
green you or friend described cash up
what is it don't look at the paper cash
app lets people give you set up your
notice in cash yeah no you can't say app
oh but ok well the application the
application this this sponsor you lets
people gift and demand those fat juicy
bags of coins
you didn't say money dollar phone by
split pace and receive she's so smart
finally you sign up for the cash app use
the promo code Whitney and not only will
you instantly receive 10 bucks right off
the bat go buy yourself some toilet
paper
during the corona crunch and cash app is
also going to donate ten dollars to The
Trevor Project an amazing organization
that what does it do provides Protective
Services to lgbtq+ I a what's I a four
people comes intersex asexual now I
youth across America
don't forget promo code Whitney when you
download the cash app from the App Store
today is it today it's today are you
sure you positive anytime you want to
download it just use that okay Whitney
[Music]
are we doing cans or no can fucking
David Sedaris I can't believe you David
Sedaris is against your fucking podcast
I mean he's like the Big B he's like the
great white whale he's the reason he's
the first book I read her ever read as a
grownup like we're a grown-up where I
went wrong I'll tell you want to know
you want to know by the way you guys are
gonna really appreciate this I am born a
meathead Miami guys my name is Bert
Kreischer I'm special streaming right
now on Netflix called hey big boy check
it out
you even need me here to discuss no no
no no oh no no I know I know how I've
been waiting to do the show I feel like
I'm a good fit for this show so so David
Sedaris I'm reading I'm reading naked on
a bus in New York right yes and I'm
laughing hysterically yeah I'm crying
laughing this guy Steve I wish you
remember his last name he was the editor
of Us magazine and he was a good friend
of ours to Tampa open money took me to
our first gay bar saw two dudes but fuck
in in the Meatpacking District exactly
circle back to that nope I think you got
it dude had stars little stars starting
at his heels of his feet going all the
way up to his butt cheeks where they
were like Dallas Cowboys stars and I was
mesmerized by this guy was watching him
and then he very slowly went over to a
guy he was like everyone's dancing was
like a gay dance club went over and sat
on his lap and I started having anal sex
and I went oh shut up and by the way I'm
a natural-born meathead I could not stop
watching I was like I could I was like I
have lots of questions about that
because it was the circle back to
Davidson or yes it is yes it is and
don't take this personally David that we
just got straight to but fucking we'll
get back to you is when you watch porn
you're watching guys I've had issue with
that I have a hard time watching
below job porn because I go I'm just
watching a dick going in out of a mouth
well Rach yeah like it's and and there's
one where I was talking to Tommy about
this the other day I saw a blowjob form
with Rocco's Freddy's and Santa
Savannah Sampson where I kept swallowing
throughout it I kept going oh my god
this is a really aggressive blowjob like
oh wait also are people still knowing
porn stars oh I thought that was a good
thing in the past so explain to me what
it is because I do have a big question
for you about porn okay namely first of
all when it comes to knowing porn stars
why do guys pick certain porn stars
because there's some there's an
endearing kind of loyalty to that like
even you guys have to commit do a porn
star like if you like a cheatin on your
porn favorite porn star yeah yeah yeah
so like I'll find like definitely the
girl follows me on Twitter I'll check
out her work I have no I have no problem
with that whatsoever uh first porn star
ever followed was jenna jameson
there was jenna jameson had sex in a
safari outfit with a guy in Safari
outfit and there was something real
about it it was she did something where
it seemed like she wanted to like it
felt consensual
yeah well Tommy I just talked about this
there's a part of porn stardom in that
happened when like when like Sugar Ray
was big where it was like when she
remembers a great went to would do what
you want still I feel like he began the
sparrow tattoos either by the way oh
yeah we were doing the tour bus doing
horrible accents of the Italian
processor giving giving speeches to the
attackers you know one thing you've got
love normal area trapper so what were we
talking so that there was a during that
period porn stars were doing this like
no one talks like that no one has sex
like that and so for me was very
disconnected
I needed someone who's like was like um
yeah you're trembling are you okay I
just wanted real stuff and so um so and
Jenny Jamison was the first one I saw
where she she grabbed on to the guy and
like like his butt yeah it was like it
was like like they were hat like they
were really having sex and I want like
she wanted it she wanted it to happen
and shoes and she was actually having
sex and that was like that was the first
time where I was like okay now I
understand why you find a pornstar and
then there's sound like there's some
like like some feel fake in performative
and some feel authentic and like she's
actually enjoying it there's a yeah
there's one girl that is actually I got
this is gonna sound creepy from me but
too young for me she's like mid-20s
the girl's great no oh no she's awesome
by the way she wasn't her I remember
because there was a lot of hype around
her and she actually like got a Steven
Soderbergh movie I remember like who's
this bitch and so I remember looking at
her up and she would suck guys dicks and
look them in the eye I had a joke I
pulled out of this special about that I
go in real life if in real life if the
girl's gonna do that if it's my wife
she's looking at me because I'm drunk
and I'm taking too long like so let me
ask you something does because porn
we know fucks up women's heads because
it's these unrealistic expectations do
guys get insecure when they watch porn
and see someone fuck girl well are they
like ah shit I know I don't think I
think makes me go it may it I watch I'm
not even shitting you I watch this guy
on gray is this him his on his leg are
mesmerizing okay this is he always
starts off with his jeans on he always
is great he really puts it down shit
about him on his podcast I go he's like
one of those skinny little guys it's got
a big dick and he just I was like you
know I'm gonna try to take my time with
it with LeAnn cuz so when you're married
so often you just have sex to get it
like do it I'm home let's do it
and then we'll get back to everything
and then I thought like knock it out
like bang one out of pork knock it out
bang one out of the park yeah and so put
one of the books you know so so how do
you okay very curious enjoy I have not
have so many questions about your
relationship
I have not been in a relationship long
enough to be able to relate I've lived
with people I have never dated someone
where we wanted to have sex at the same
time truly never really it's always like
I can't like I have like 30 minutes when
I get home if you miss that window
that's it
you seemed we were actually talking
about this on the bus you seem like you
seem like very like like almost it's
scheduled in like I was like you come
home be like okay I'm gonna get enough
sauna and off 20 minutes unless this is
gonna happen now yeah you missed your
window yeah that's it
and I just put on my expense of face
cream so you can't touch my face I have
to be on the bottom I'm turning right
like no spontaneity allowed sealian is
very I didn't get to do crunches today
so can I be on the bottom I can do my
kegels like by the way when I was in
good shape I'd be stuff like yellow I'll
definitely on top burn some calories now
I'm like I'm gonna definitely on my back
lands lost like 16 pounds wow it looks
amazing and I kind of hate it
and so mmm and so no I I if we almost
have sex I always want I said but you
just look at each other and you're like
we got five minutes she'll say stuff
like she'll say stuff like yeah just put
a pop-tart in we got 30 seconds it's
always something something big boy like
like yeah he want to go go go take a
bath big boy and you'd be like and
that's like oh yeah you have to have a
southern accent to pull that off Oh
everyone in my family calls me Big Boy
but Leanne does it Leah you can tell the
ants like planting some seeds yes yes do
you guys like swagger though with that
she uh she was younger she was a fucking
fiction like like like a fucking Tomcat
like honestly I'm the best at this is
this why I love my wife which first let
me start with what is your definition of
love believe me I love that I think I'm
a prenup okay
I could not function without Leanne I
literally could not function without
Leanne so I hope she's cool with me
sharing this but I miss the this is why
so when we were dating we just did what
20 years ago I'll be 18
go 18 years ago 17 years ago we're both
in great shape and she's like hey let's
get away from this let's go for a ride
on the lake wait she has a lake house in
Alabama Alabama power so it's this huge
lake with these like little inlets that
you can like kind of disappear and kind
of find stuff in and now we do it with
the girls it's funny shit
but back then we'd go back and Leanne
gets back in this little jetty takes off
all her clothes off the jetski and jumps
in the water and it's like come on get
in order and I was like I'm by the way
I'm I grew up in Florida I'm terrified
of fucking alligators I say I will
hardly get in my own bathtub if there's
too many bubbles oh so now I'm like fuck
it I'm just thing about leeches inside
mine I'm thinking of oh so I take off my
pants and we start skinny-dipping and it
turns into probably the most memorable
sexual experience I've ever had in my
entire weight are your feet touching the
bottom no we're swimming and then how
are you getting any good without
drowning each other we get together we
end up on a jet ski I mean it's just it
is it is like you're in really good
shape
oh I remember yeah an epic UTI have that
no no we had an amazing time right so
I've always thought about this one time
I've thought about it so much so like
last time were at the lake and I go I'm
like I go hey let's let's disappear on
the jet skis let's go back to that place
we let's do the same thing honey we're
not in the kind of shape you were back
then she goes do you want to ruin a
perfectly great memory with me and you
trying to recreate it she goes let's not
do that let's just have that great
memory okay and I was like my asshole oh
how did you guess one year I go to moon
someone on a boat someone pulls out the
gas pump sprays into my ass gets a
little hot then again now I'm in the
water
grubbing it gasoline salt water asshole
not a good combo
I literally slammed swam to an island
and was naked sound like a miner clean
the skillet just get the fuck gasoline
your value if you take anything out of
this interview and you're young boy do
not get gassing your asshole that brings
me to a question before we get back to
the porn stuff is bent and I were
fighting yesterday by the way Fenton is
one of my favorite individuals dead oh I
didn't want to say that to him when I
walked in there's something very
favorite very very very endearing
everyone's favorite Pooh Bear in
Hollywood yeah I mean everyone's
obsessed with my little Pooh Bear yeah
just met him in Nashville they said do
you want I want a local person and they
said how about this guy went okay went
on destroyed yeah to the point where I
was like okay easy buddy let's pump the
brakes maybe light him early
follow this and then um brought him out
here and here he is and he's spending
all his new money on kimonos and Cabala
bracelets was $4 thank you very much and
Benton is not scared of me challenges me
and finds pleasure in embarrassing me in
front of my kids and what are we
fighting about yesterday you said we
were fighting about Oh what holes so
right now there's a too many people are
buying toilet paper people are running
out of toilet paper because of what's
happening with Corona and people are
saying in order to save toilet paper you
should get a bidet attachment problem I
don't understand how it cleans your life
changing asshole no it's for your
asshole first time I ever used one was
in Japan as another joke I took out of
the special I took a shit in Japan so
bad the guy in the stall next to me
threw up and we were in Japan I thought
he was talking to me oh and so I was
like I don't have any toilet paper
special because I had another one that
was just like it and I liked the other
one better it was more socially eating
experiences that were I loved shitting
in public
I loved shitting in public are you one
of those people that can't shit and then
you leave the house and then all the
sudden you have to shit no I just I've
known those people if we had to eat I go
are you guys almost done all right I'm
gonna take a shit
every time every time you pussy I say
the same joke every time no cheek that's
like yeah okay this is are your immune
system is so sure I identify why you can
fucking Lakes yeah I say the same joke
every time I go to get shit at a
restaurant if I'm not back in 10 minutes
sending a charger
no one ever fucking like that I'll tell
you my other joke that I fucking always
do is a dad joke but I love it any time
we see a sunset and right when it crests
over the horizon everyone goes aw soon
as everyone turns before hey to walk
away I go oh my god it's coming back up
and everyone turns around makes me laugh
I do that every I love a good dad joke
you know what you want to know when I
did the other day on stage I went out to
quarters and I put him on the stool
they're like are you serious and I was
like yeah when you got there tell me if
you see patty Sutton they're like what's
50 cent doing his Sacramento I was like
I have no idea I just went on the stage
I saw every single one of them went out
to the stage went motherfucker endearing
about that is I think that because as
comedians we don't get to enjoy comedy
the way other people enjoy comedy we
watch smart incisive great comedy we go
fuck I should have thought of that yeah
but dumb dumb that's all we can really
enjoy you should have seen the look on
their face the next night when I said
you're never gonna believe this but
Eminem Eminem is out there with him just
like that stupid joke the hardest I've
laughed in a couple years cuz again when
we see brilliant comedy we don't really
laugh we're just like fuck that was good
yeah you know like we and this is what
part of my theory about why comedians
are sad is because we are robbed of
being able to enjoy comedy see I I can
I'm pretty lucky in that I can't watch I
can't watch I can watch certain people I
can't watch anybody alright just anybody
I like I definitely can't watch anybody
special anymore I used to be able to do
that it was so much fun and now I can't
no I think nobody can you know let me
give you this little antidote of when I
was in Netflix you know when you go in
and they they tell you all about the
algorithm and they tell you about tears
the posters we're gonna use in here is
all the art we're gonna use and you know
they use different posters for different
algorithm
and and the head of comedy said to me
maybe said it to you too when your
special comes out it it might not be on
your home screen don't panic
that just means it's your algorithm
right and I was like wait a second
he's like every comedian calls me the
day their special comes out and look why
the fuck isn't my special on my homepage
yeah that means you don't watch stand-up
specials oh and most comedians don't
watch other people's day I watch on
Netflix is secret time my first breath I
watched yours I watched a watch / I
watched Chappelle I watched I watched
Tommy's last time I watch Tommy's came
out before me and I watched his just to
make sure we didn't have any similar
yeah that's smart that's my like I'll
check because sometimes you're like oh
that's good lighting
oh that's too many crowd shots oh why do
they keep cutting the crowd like it's
also good to just see what is working
for you and what is and I also I have
this thing I haven't really figured this
out yet but I have this thing where it's
it's hypochondria yeah with guilt huh so
like so like I'll give you a perfect
example on this special I have a joke
that I posted on social media like two
weeks ago you know - for the trailer of
this blowjob joke which one the one that
what's that it's a blowjob no no yeah
and then and then the end is my wife one
of stuff to me if she's she if I'm sick
I definitely of sex with she or her she
said yeah yeah and she's like I don't
want to get you sick I was like well
practice safe sex she's like you're in
or Economo no doggystyle so you can call
from the wall right I wrote that joke
maybe 16 months ago obviously eighteen
months ago was we started working on
this at this hour recorded it in
November we posted it online and then
the crota virus comes out and everyone
hears my joke and goes it'll just meme
it here's what happens to me I wish I
could stop this I start in my head
believing I stole that joke
believing it I believe it I'll give you
a perfect sample my buddy Blaire Mendez
and I live together him and this guy
Jimmy live downstairs I lived upstairs
hutch lived in the other room Blaire one
day comes over and goes hey you didn't
by any chance go through my sock drawer
did you I said no
why would I honestly why would I would
never go to anyone's talk to her and he
goes I'm missing like 700 bucks
I immediately immediately yeah yeah
start behaving like I've stolen 700 I
but any time you try to convince someone
you didn't do something you always sound
like you're lying that's just three
years later I go I go this has really
been bothering me you know I did you
know I didn't do that later and I was
like but there's when you deny something
you seem guilty right away and I find
that the person that didn't do it
would've gone like oh that's weird
and just kept on with their day who but
I do think it's interesting you say that
because when I'm late to like dinner or
something or like a spot or something
like Adam of the comedy star if I'm like
I'm running 20 minutes late there's
traffic I feel the need to send a
picture of the traffic yep because I
well they probably think I'm lying but I
did use to fucking lie a lot I did used
to douche I used to be like oh there's
traffic when there wasn't like I
definitely in my twenties would lie a
lot like I come from people that lied a
lot exaggerating a lot and I'm so
paranoid I'm so paranoid that like this
is how crazy I was the first time it
ever happened I had a joke you know what
talk you know what cops hate when you
touch their faces we don't I wrote I
wrote it in with in Newton Scotland when
I was with Patrice O'Neal the real story
is I touched a flight attendants face
off and she was like I saw I'm sorry sir
I can't give you and I just took my
finger and Patrice's next to me and he
was like I tried onstage and Patrice
like now you got to up the ante and
flight attendant doesn't he goes it
doesn't work he cares yeah he's like try
cop
Dave Chappelle does a special and he's
doing a joke about him and his buddy
getting pulled over by the cops room
great and immediately this is so bizarre
immediately I go oh fuck his might is he
gonna tell my touching the cop space
joke this and then I start like he
obviously didn't I don't no one's ever
told this joke but me but I'm not
believing in a weird way and like a
hypochondria kind of way like I must
have seen him do it nicely I can't have
a joke done yeah yeah I can't believe
just
so kevin Christie friend of ours at the
Comedy Store comedian who comes on the
road me sometimes I if I write a good
joke I text him I go someone doing this
joke and he's like no that's a great
joke and I'm like are you sure I thought
of this I did that to Stanhope the other
day I was like there's no way I fuckin
came up with this yeah I mean because
sometimes you'll tell a joke and it'll
just come out so good and you're like oh
that's way too perfect I remember when I
was like 2 sometimes they're not your
jokes sometimes you're you've sometimes
like you'll come up and you'll be
improper you'll go dot and then someone
will be like you know it I've done that
before I was on stage and I said
something about my wife needs me or
something like that I got off stage and
someone's like I think that it might be
a Patrice joke and I went oh my god it
totally is were you just writing in the
moment yeah and you you've got to be
very cognizant that's right and that's
that's why I do spots to the store
because all your friends will call you
on that shit that's right that's right
oh no every time thank you if you're
doing something very derivative yeah
we're similar little text you
immediately like it's like you know I'm
doing this whole bit on like how
dangerous playgrounds were where we grew
up and just when we grew up you know
like our slides were made of metal and
merry-go-rounds like how dangerous
everything was people think phones are
so dangerous and all this shit and I
have this whole thing of about jungle
gyms and and how there was no shade on
our slides of shit and like Fortran was
like hey just so you know I'm doing a
bit about this and here's what I but it
was so like okay what are you doing what
am i doing let's just figure out a way
to we both been put six months into this
let's figure out a way to both be able
to do these I'll do that if it's towards
the bits close to my special yeah I'll
go like I'll be like all right hold on
let me hear your bit yeah and then and
then I'll figure out where the
similarities lay usually mine are very
different because I I attempt I had a
real epiphany with Adam at the store one
time where he get he told me a joke he
lied he liked a mine and I didn't see it
as a joke in minutes and I was like I
thought that's not even a bit and he was
like oh my god it's like my favorite
thing you do it was a joke about my
bought my wife's pajamas for Christmas
and she said she wanted pajamas so I
bought her seven pairs of pajamas an
individually wrapped them not realizing
that we know she opened them she open
the first one she said Oh pajamas I was
like fuck if that's a reaction
number one the children the same we say
no more pajamas my guys the next me
looks at the 500 me goes oh you're a
fucking idiot buy pajamas number seven
they are pissing that's a shorthand a
destroyed very simple story but I didn't
see it as a bit and Adam goes oh no
that's totally like a Bert bit and so I
started to attempt to write different
than other comics I didn't want to have
traditional set up punches I wanted to
have stories and I wanted to complicate
them I wanted to get them to a point
where where you would plant something
early that could come in later I really
kind of like challenged myself on a
secret time to do that
and I did it a couple times and then on
this one I was like I was like I have
one joke that I'm so proud of I hope
people like it that I'm like it's my
favorite joke I've ever fuck ever told
and I don't I'm not ready to retire it
so I'm like because it's it's it's like
everything I attempted to be against the
grain with what you're doing yeah you
know it's like you do you ever feel like
at this point there's a joke that you
try to make work and you could just
never fucking get it there you ready
yeah just told it today I just told it
today it's my my wife and my daughters
call me the patriarchy so so we're
sitting help me write this joke so it
does not work so it is so okay what's
wrong with men okay sometimes I mean my
last four special you're so used to
being right all the time to a corner of
being a fucking idiot
my daughter's wanted to start
skateboarding and so I was like cool I
go ahead why because we live on a busy
busy street but people drive up our
street at rush hour I go why don't I get
cones traffic cones and my wife says oh
baby you can't just buy traffic cones
white mass
I look like all of our presidents
combined
and I just go on Amazon and I see
traffic cones and I know they're hard to
get up and they're kind of expensive
it's like it's like hundred dollars for
its it's 53 dollars for one traffic cone
okay so I go and it's it's a size 8 so
size 8 size 8 so I go BAM I got four
traffic cones goes excuse me I go I
think you're wrong I bought four traffic
cones and she goes hit but it's probably
not the regular ones I go there size
eight and Georgia goes sighs hey yes
eyes eight it's an eight traffic cone
mom dad just spent $200 on traffic cones
she goes mom I think I've bought 34
traffic cones 30 36 traffic cones
I go no baby they're size eight okay
she's no dead they're eight traffic
cones you've got four packs of eight
traffic cones for $50 oh no I did in
Georgia she does know you did and I go
death Georgia they're size eight I don't
even I don't even know where I'm
defending this from any other size eight
and then I like oh yeah a lot of times
you come back from the doctor and the
doctors like wow you're almost two sizes
of eight traffic cones hi and I'm like
huh and then they start looking for bone
they go no no you bought 38 six traffic
cones and I went no did it they didn't
say anything right the next day they
deliver they're putting out guns to
Bhargav like that if the coronavirus
right I don't know I wanted
some light immediately I swear to God in
this special it made me laugh so hard
the joke that you posted about your wife
walking in on you watching porn yeah and
watch this crazy blowjob dinner saying
what was that
so do guys watch porn that are like
different than what they're getting in
their relationship like here one time
I'm dating this guy I take his phone to
like order something and his YouTube
porn comes up he didn't delete his
cookies or whatever yeah so I see
and he had googled big budded porn big
budded girl
BBG i don't know what it is and i do not
have a very big butt and I remember
going oh my god he's filling in for what
I don't have porn he's watching and then
I was like if I had a huge butt would he
want like pancake butt if I had big
boobs would he want to see small boobs
or am I just trying to make sense of
something that make you trying to make
sense of by the way of a guy who just
was like got on pornhub he started
school in the 100 you doing I'm good to
you I ask you why would you why is there
a popular page or an hub
why are you like I want to see what
other people are jerking off to this is
not what I'm into doggy style
anal and ass to mouth while I met this
girl online
I also by the way not at all by the way
not even professionally shot well I've
actually watched this the consequence is
boat on the bed and then fucks over his
phone and at one point they move over
and as a person I'm like God move your
fucking phone landscape good
cinematography no I sometimes it's just
is especially if you open a guy's phone
and it's it's the first thing up it's
just someone walked in and he was just
but you don't need to feel insecure
about what your guy is watching on porn
it's not I'm gonna look up things that I
don't normally get to see at home
no and I would feel very insecure if
Liam was like dudes with black dudes
with big dicks I'd be like and I saw
that on her phone Wow hold on yeah I'd
be like let's talk about this what would
happen I would be extreme
[Laughter]
fucking huh I'm drinking I'm like I may
drink tonight I had a dream that she had
a dream that I had a dream last night
that she cheated on me and I woke up
very very angry because she did stuff
this with that guy that she wouldn't let
me do with her like he just ripped her
pants off her I was like whoa she
doesn't do that and he was like she does
with me I woke up so mad that III then
in the dream I'm not only women got mad
about things that men did in there went
back to sleep - to find this guy and
hurt me and he goes we're gonna club his
foot and I went what he was don't worry
I got this we're gonna drill holes and
his knees and his hands and then club
one of his feet like misery just and I
was like god Tom straight-up Nancy
Kerrigan and so yeah I would I would be
there I would be heartbroken but I think
LeAnn knows that anything I watch on
porn is just bizarre oh it's not there's
no rhyme or reason has never had a
problem that I don't think we had cares
about me enough like I think she or she
is feel so secure in your relationship
that she knows it's not a threat - she
knows very well she knows very well that
I am first of all I'm like weird about
diseases so I'm not like a guy that goes
out and have honest I've never had a ton
of sex yeah million sex with six chicks
yeah well I'm not but I'm not that guy I
fall in love and so and then that's my
thing mm-hmm it's like you know if they
- me - for drugs and alcohol I'm fucked
yeah yeah
when me two came out I was like yeah
it's not it's never been me yeah I have
been the guy that has dated girls like
gone out on dates with girls and never
kissed them Wow cuz I get nervous about
that first kiss no no Mike you it I'd
rather just break up with them it's not
worth it
dude keep in touch with any exes one
yeah one yeah one how's that does
Landcare know I've seen a couple maybe
yeah but yeah one night one came to a
show but she was such a she's not
I don't think LeAnn has any fear of her
whatsoever
and the girl was a really a really
blessing in my life at a weird time as
when the Rolling Stone article came out
I always say this I said this to someone
the other day but like I told a girl
that I dated like five years I told her
I wanted to be a comedian one more
we were mourning for the Florida State
Miami game and she said oh honey you're
not you're not smart funny you're stupid
funny like if you want to be clean you
gotta be smart funny and you're not
smart funny
you're like dumb frat boy funny and
that's not comedian stuff and then I was
like okay no itself never told him when
your dreams Jesus and then I dated this
girl who I say this kindly but was just
just I don't mean dumb enough but just
[Laughter]
you should totally do my god did it work
you could do it like the kind of person
that you'd be like I think I wanna start
a race really was really and she was
very supportive we ended up breaking up
because she became unsupportive or
whatever refer out of a reason but but
yeah I saw her and she came out to one
of my shows that I'd like sold out a sum
couple theaters or in her town but she
was like she was like wow like can you
believe you did this and I was like no
by the way I don't think without you
thinking I could have done it I don't
think like when Rolling Stone article
came out everyone was like it's very
polarized very few people were like
because I'd said in the article if it is
you that don't know I was written up in
Rolling Stone magazine when I was in
twenty five saying that I was the number
one party animal the country it wasn't
huge and I want to ask you about did
Oliver Stone really option ya up to the
doors you know I'm obsessed with Oliver
Stone everyone I've seen your honors
thesis on JFK I met Oliver Stone one
time I want to know all about it was a
good morning america and I get in the
elevator
I'm with the whole Travel Channel team
and there's another team already in the
elevator and the doors are open and
they're like hold hold hold
do you mind if we wait for Oliver Stone
and Oliver Stone Natural Born Killers
platoon yep one of the greatest
directors at the time I forget her in
the movie he was coming out with at the
time but anyway I go here's my chance
I'm gonna say him I'm gonna say to him
miss stone my name's Bert Kreischer in
1997 Rolling Stone magazine wrote an
article about me so many at your company
optioned the rights to my life and that
gave me the confidence to get into
stand-up and without that I don't know
if I would be in this elevator with you
today I know you PI don't remember this
but I just want to say thank you very
much for that whoever that was that
option the rights to my
so he gets in the thing he's high as
fuck
oh and and and I go mr. stone and
someone goes oh my god you're Bert
Kreischer went on his team and I go I am
and they're like Oliver Oliver this guy
is hilarious he's one of the funny he's
got a show on Travel Channel called
birth to conquer that is amazing but
he's a great stand-up and I'm like okay
and then we're going down we're going
he's like well where do you do comedy
and I said out of LA and he goes oh I
think he does Joe Rogan's podcast you
got to see this guy's hilarious and he's
like uh-huh
great doors open and like a script
meeting you I didn't say word I was like
fuck it I have my in and out I'm done
yeah but my boy got in trouble I mean
when I wrote a senior on a thesis on JFK
I was so obsessed with that movie and
his work in general and I wrote letters
to his office this is back when I
thought that that's how you like get
jobs you like Sony by the way Whitney
thank you for your time and
consideration with my like AOL email and
my phone number I will love to intern in
your office like I thought people would
open them and read them you saying this
Whitney would have made if this was
1930s it would have made one man very
wealthy it's Christmas we're sending out
letters to everyone he's a god give me
another whiskey on she's a don't worry
I'll Drive Betsy Ross John flags
yeah Oliver Stone that gave me the
confidence to do stand-up he they
optioned the rights to my life I
submitted a script called the under
undergraduates and and then and then I
moved to New York and then Will Smith
discovered my six months later and I
moved to and then he gave me the comment
he taught me at it's all by the way I
and I hate that like I've told the story
about thinking will sitteth one enough
sex with me I've set it up and I hate
that he would ever hear that and not
enjoy that story yeah cuz it's a funny
fucking story and it's true what he
taught me how to sell a TV show yeah he
taught me everything I know everything I
currently use in this business I learned
watching one of the most I'm not sure
I'm using this word right magnanimous
mmm-hmm gregarious human beings I've
ever seen in my life
Wow his energy could change a room it
was like magic to watch him come in and
be like like it was and so it's always
the reason he's
Smith yeah it cuz that comes through on
camera that charisma and that you can't
fake that kind of like having a good
heart yeah and so then and then and then
I got a TV show I got a TV show really
quickly and and and then everything and
then it all got taken away from me and
that was the biggest blessing is fucking
losing everything how long did it take
for you to realize it was a blessing
[Music]
probably like now I think now I can
realize as a blessing because it forced
me to lean back into stand up really
hard and and it also forced me to do
Travel Channel which I never would have
dunks I needed money and I think and if
it wasn't for it I always say this I say
this ad nauseum aphorism for friends
like burr and Rogin and Segura I would
never have gotten away from Travel
Channel and I never want gotten into
podcasting is heavier I'm telling you
man
the one thing in this business that is
so valuable is like legit friends who
especially when they're more successful
than you cuz they're not competing with
you yeah and they're just telling you to
do your doing wrong yep and how you can
fix it I think that and I'm very I
defend female comics especially the ones
that are competitive and not girls girls
because I do think first of all in order
to become a female comedian at least my
generation and older you had to sort of
you had to be an alpha you probably had
to defend yourself at a young age you
were probably you guys were savages very
I would watch you guys operate and just
take a step back a very long time I
understand my female comedians are so
competitive because when I started one
per line up max I'm so glad I'm a man
because I got to be able to hang I'm a
man to be able to hang back in the cut
until I was like 40 years old and then
oh and then and and and and not and not
have to be not have to be an alpha and
not have to fight for my one spot a
night or fighting one spot and also I
had a because I was also doing
television and on camera
especially when high-definition came in
this was before it was like body
positivity was a thing and you know and
it was you have a ticking clock on you
you're eight you're getting older and
you get scripts to play a mom at 32
you're a mom of three and you have a
ticking clock in terms of touring
because once you have kids touring is
you know gonna be a nightmare and you're
gonna get old and ugly and all that your
fertility there's that too and then
there's also the there's there can only
be one of us it's and there's I have to
be twice as good to be respected thank
God I got to be half as good and for
twice as long you know what a lot of
podcasts they have to read off these
pieces of paper because they don't
actually use the products that sponsor
them I use ritual
I'm gonna go off-book here this is a
fish oil pill that I really very much
take every day and it has little balls
in it that are minty so that you don't
have Worf breaths you know I mean you
keep you healthy keep things on point
took two this morning to try to beat
that corona ritual and it's a
subscription so you don't have to go you
run out and then be like where's my
visual and go order it like an asshole
this is a great bag I don't even need to
read it but I'm authentic I mean it
rituals essential for women helps fill
gaps in a woman's diet with essential
for women and all set that helps support
a healthy foundation for your body yes
and you don't get any that fishy
aftertaste yeah I said that nailed it
there's no oh yeah there's no bullshit
in it there's no it's GMOs there's no
gluten or food coloring or read number
five better health doesn't happen
overnight and right now ritual is
offering my listeners your listeners our
listeners 10% off your first three
months fill in the gaps within your diet
with essentials for woman's a small step
that helps support a healthy foundation
for your body your WOM and Lea Bondi
ritual comm / Whitney to start your
ritual today that's 10% off during your
first three months at ritual dot-com /
wit I didn't need to read it cuz I'm
honest
you know me I don't I don't we met I
don't like going to see shows mostly
because getting tickets is a nightmare
that said today deferred 3 today tix is
my new jam because you can get tickets
on this app it's called todaytix and
they have they have good prices to
theatre
good I'm not reading off this I'm trying
to be authentic and just explain it
because this is something I actually do
but I guess I'll read it great prices on
top shows all in one place you download
the app at todaytix comm whether you're
looking for musicals plays comedies
dance stand up which we actually do
every now and then if this corona would
Adkins booked your tickets months in
advance very helpful or 30 seconds or
less or not 30 seconds before the show
it takes 30 seconds or less
we just lost this sponsor booked in
advance or the day of no matter where
you live it's not just Broadway and
London was and you can also find tickets
in cities across the country finally see
that show you've been waiting to see
forever discover something new that you
just will love as much as the thing you
loved forever go to detect it go to
today tix.com slash Whitney and who's
the Braille code Whitney to get $10 off
your first todaytix purchase that's
promo code Whitney at todaytix t IX
dot-com / Whitney for $10 off your first
ticket purchased today take / Whitney
we've talked about this little pocket
what is this obsession with feet I just
told the girl who gave me the obsession
I told her in New York that she was the
reason I'm a foot fetish and she's like
a mom with you kids what Jennifer
Stephen and executors Oh 8 grade wait do
you know that Freud's theory about why
men are in defeat is cuz toes look like
dicks then then sign me up for 10 baby
dicks because I love feet I'll tell you
what man I saw Michael Jackson was in
defense look Jamie
Jennifer's demons was I just told her
this and it made her very uncomfortable
she's a legit mom yeah like I'm 18 year
old in a 15 year old there are fans of
mine they'll see this it's changed her
name she's married to one of my best
friends growing up so yeah there's no
way to edit this Stephen say Johnny
shallots a CMOS a John dude
Stephen st. John and I lived to run was
apart from each other we were like best
friends growing up he ended up marrying
her she's still an awesome fucking yeah
she was it they came to earn like now
remember crystal all these girls came to
my show hey girl
crystal said that's a hot one Regis and
Kathie friends with one of the promoters
I saw her at the show she was at your
show let me get shoulder
I feel like Deborah crystal use it a lot
Aqua Net model like frosty lipstick no
pepper crystal had press-on nails
Deborah crystal was obsessed with New
York in at her Bat Mitzvah it was all
about New York AB she was destined to go
to New York okay so they're all my tour
bus we're having drinks and we just done
the beacon and there and they're like
they're like like they used to see me at
the improv they're like holy shit like
yeah and we've just bullshitting and I
said something and I she they're like
you used all this regular names and you
act like you don't change anything I go
no no I said I talked about you Jennifer
she's like I said I talked about it one
time that you're the person that gave me
a foot fetish and she's like oh my god
she had perfectly tan feet gorgeous
perfectly tan feet and she would cross
her legs and dangle her shoe like play
with her shoe with her foot in history
class mystery arnelle's class and I
would stare at that foot and go I didn't
know what it was about it I was like
just the foot eighth grade seventh grade
eighth grade eighth grade eighth grade
we were learning about barnstorming very
important you get boners know that you
knew no I was just like it was like what
is it do you want to fuck them or you
would put your mouth I just want to go
like I leave got nothing is more
disgusting to me than feet oh I have
gorgeous feet
I had a pleats foot when I was like
eight so I've always been disgusted by
just all feet oh no no no I am I also
have toenails that fall off they look
like marbles that are sucking toes
Marvel's that are sucking cookie now
this toenail fell
and so I had to just do a movie and I
had to wear flip-flops so I just painted
the skin all right let me see your foot
put your foot out like stretch it out so
give it a give it a fucking fighting
care I have very arched feet okay a
great arts feet I have very arched feet
and oh I also have a black ankle I um
why do you have black ankles do diabetes
no I also by the way have an extra toe
in my foot I I have an extra bone in my
foot for like I haven't evolved entirely
and I went to a foot doctor and he's
like oh you have an extra bone in your
foot like your ancestors have it fully
evolved I also get hair on my toes okay
okay that's a yes well those are blond
hairs yeah no you don't have a bad you
don't have bad for your toenails
definitely need some work on my left
foot another toenail came off cuz I used
to rollerblade all the time in college
and Philly hold on that needs to be a
t-shirt I used to rollerblade that's a
great way to start it this oh now that's
a great foot you think oh it's a great
foot this toenail came off and now this
is a great foot yeah yeah if you get
that foot to look like this one if I
were you I just everywhere you go just
like one foot behind it's just fun but
this is a bad leg because I've got all
Jewish ladders I've got like a nice
water yeah I've got a nice buddy has
that I haven't your to see that try and
think like though thank you I
that's me from walking into you I will
say this um never mind I just say please
I feel like a compliment what's coming
I'll ah I love your body no I think your
great body I think it was great great
yeah this was I saw you were doing
something other day and you were showing
off your body and I was like I was like
what you got a great buy I've never
looked at your body like that but yeah
but you got one bad foot thank you one
good one club fight good hands I feel
like I've disgusting been picking up
coal why are your fingers so Brown by
the way I have she's picking up
earthworms raining outside to the earth
worms
to carry them back to the flooded mud
they were trying to flee
oh fuck did I bury them I just killed I
bury them alive back into the wet ground
oh no this because I've been constantly
washing my hands because this fucking
pandemic we're in but I felt like me
what you're a better basketball player
than any of those
you're a legit good basketball player
yeah I am it's weird nobody would know
that but I played very serious
basketball for a very long time woody I
don't think there's anything you didn't
do very seriously
think there's anything you phoned it in
on I feel like your perception of me is
that I am a workaholic no I just think
that I think you wake up with purpose I
don't think you wake up like like I do
where you're like oh man not today
coronavirus what I said this morning
morning I wake up going like hold my
breath for 10 seconds I don't have it
hey Jackie go but I wake up with fear in
my heart fear of failure fear of falling
behind fear of not living up to my
potential in fear of getting older as a
woman in this business because I truly
feel I have in my head this clock which
is so Anathem that's probably when you
get better as a comic but my brain is
like you're gonna expire at 40 you have
till 40 no which is probably when I'll
be the best you need to mathlete Matt
you need to mash up a tablet with LeAnn
LeAnn is the polar fucking opposite
mm-hmm like at one point I said
something I was fucking drunk and I said
something about her looked like she was
aging on her nose like right there and I
was like oh yeah I didn't even realize I
did it gotta make sure her self-esteem
stays low so she'd believe you she was
like oh no I'm excited about getting old
like I'm not gonna stop this and I went
what she goes this is what life is this
is the next stage of beauty is to be an
open shoes I really want old hands I
don't know what she goes my granny's
hands like we watch them make biscuits
and you go oh those those hands know how
to make biscuits look at those hands and
I was like that's such a weird way to
look at life I'm not like that I'm like
yeah because I think it's cause we're in
Hollywood like I love the idea of
getting older because I look at myself
in my 20s and I'm so embarrassed about
my behavior and my character back then
you know like when you're at your
youngest and fittest sir oh my god you
are at your dumbest hauled at who I was
I was unconscious I mean I was truly
unconscious I mean I just finished
making all my apologies to people from
things I've done in my twenties like I
just finished I feel like I'm still 33
I don't feel 47 you do look this same
age of when I first met I don't feel
like I haven't you are ageless you are
in bombed you're drinking the perfect
amount of yourself let's start looking
very young like it's fucking insane like
when I stopped drinking my skin clears
up yeah yeah during the sauna which is a
game changer for the skin truly me too I
started doing the sauna I I think I look
incredible I've never said that about
myself I have very low self-esteem and I
think I look at media knows when you
when you're in a sauna I go or videotape
myself in a sauna she looks awesome I
feel like I'm doing that cuz you do it
oh I do it because you do it I basically
do whatever you do on your stories good
as Rogen he looks like a fucking
werewolf be like uncomfortable and then
I get a diet coke your mouth isn't
supposed to be sweating Jodie's
everything to the like gas things so
intensely I remember one time saying
sometimes when you text I feel like
you're doing it with your nose like him
advice it's such a good quiet well I
mean experts medical experts on my back
Bernie Sanders just the best in the
world of whatever they are I mean look I
think he just listens when people talk
on his shows but the last special I was
doing it seems like starting now and
your specials coming out a very good
time not to find the silver lining in
the corona silver lining in that because
all like mine is why I said I'm really
fucked up about this coronavirus thing
because all I think about is all the
waitresses at the store well we I just
texted about that where they are gonna
be paid and we're gonna do a thing where
we
give them some extra - yeah you want to
just how much you want to put up 40
grand you know guys it's quarantined
back in your houses watch my special and
then we'll talk about what I give them
no I think about all the older people I
think people were better one of my best
friend's has hardcore asthma him and his
daughter I think about all those people
that were this may fucking ruin their
life I think about just the idea of
going to a hospital right now knowing
that you're sick you have a heart attack
or something and there's already beds
taken up that's really what's gonna
become devastating is that so many beds
are occupied that people that have just
non Korona related things but you were
saying about Joe you well Joe which
we'll come back to that um Joe gave me
some real incredible advice because I
remember the head of Netflix comedy
calling me right before I shot up my
special and going hey can you open with
your closer basically like we're it's
hard to get people to finish specials I
don't think it will be during right now
with this quarantine thing I think
people are gonna finish pretty much
everything they want and this is when I
was sort of developing what I was gonna
do and how I'm gonna make this stand out
how am I gonna make people finish this
and I ended up building a robot to put
it again so even if someone didn't
finish it they go to a party and go yo
did you see what happened at the end and
then everyone be like even if they
didn't finish don't even get me started
you know what makes me most angry about
this Oh quarantine is I had really
planned epic promos and Mars gonna do um
we're still gonna do up here we're still
gonna do anyway we're still gonna do
them and you're still gonna do more well
here you wanna hear one that is genius
yes I was gonna I was gonna present I
was gonna do an ex FL halftime show okay
so I was gonna go ladies and gentlemen
guys on the kind of thing ladies and
gentlemen this is brilliant by the way
and I'm so angry but I won't be able to
doing it right now I won't be able to
nobody if you had seen it if you had
been there at the moment it would have
been one of the funniest things you've
ever seen okay
ladies and gentlemen today's halftime
presentation is brought to you by Bert
Kreischer Bert currently has a Netflix
comedy special streaming right now on
Netflix called hey big boy so sit back
and enjoy the oh my god there's a
streaker
then I come out right streaking please
all police officers to the field please
help us get this streaker
ladies and gentlemen do not record this
do not videotape this this will not be
aired we're supposed to be having a half
my impersonation now the cops chased me
they've catched me in the middle of the
field right they wrestle me in you hear
pom pom pom pom pom I mean the cops get
in formation how great would that have
been
right how great everyone go to laughing
hysterically and then I started going
I'm gonna do halftime presentations for
the XFL for the rest of the year ladies
and gentlemen today's presentation is
brought to you by oh my god there's
someone pears you to go into the field
like non-stop I planned all this out and
I can't do it Michael it's a door show
yeah I can't do it go back to what
Netflix are you comics come out and
spend the first five fucking minutes
doing crowd work about a city that most
people don't live in what job New York
not get me started about the what's up
guys the tag I couldn't get a taxi here
New Yorkers like most people watching
this aren't there you need it you need
to make your special for the people
watching you what are you doing on stage
I go I think I say thank you or yes or
thank you and I get right to it tell a
joke right away and then I tell another
one I don't want to lose you are you
cutting to a giant theater everyone no
one needs it why are you doing theater
porn it's really so many comedians shoot
in venues shoot their specials in ways
to try to impress other comedians or try
to make other comedians jealous and
people sitting at home they're all like
we know you can sell these tickets we're
your fans yeah why do you keep cutting
to a balcony I didn't here's what I
didn't want to do on this special I
didn't want to go up with with with what
I thought was material that I think
people would gravitate to more which was
stories about my wife my family like
stuff like that all my girls stuff
everyone loves stories about Island
Georgia
and so I didn't want to go up and do
that cuz I felt like as a viewer if you
watched it you go oh it's just more
stories about his kids I saw little
secret time like I want to see more of
him so I really challenged myself to
make sure that I did stuff that was
still very Bert yeah you know drunk
Forrest Gump kind of guy still very Bert
mm-hmm but and and then gate and then
screw out sprinkled stuff that you were
familiar with so that it wasn't and I
wasn't a carbon copy of secret time I
want to be a difference especially if
someone watch a secret time and then
watches the other one right afterwards
it's been James what I love is you have
to make specials now assuming people are
gonna watch a couple of them in one sort
of if you watch secret time and then you
start this one you're gonna go this is
this is exactly what Bert does but it's
it's done is I think it's done so much
better this I'm so proud of this special
including the name like I guess a good
time was a brilliant name for me because
that's I say that non-stop Netflix said
no to what a couple of my titles there
everyone was like Netflix never says no
to titles and they try again and burn
magical are also like yeah I wanted to
call my last special bearclaw you can't
do that yeah this it's a great title it
chappelle's the only one that's like the
the outlier on this cuz his titles the
bird prophecy or whatever you're doing
you're like huh but you're like I don't
give a fuck I love it says Dave
Chappelle in front of it Chris Rock's
being called Tambourine because I
remember going I know that's a fucking
great joke and I can't wait to see why
it's called this it made me so curious
watch it it is a it is an interesting
way to sell a special sale to sell them
watching the whole thing yeah is give a
like a nod to the thing it also annoys
me if I don't know the answer to
something and I'm like I just want to
fucking figure out why it's called that
I was initially gonna call this special
I was doing this but our very
differently I was gonna call it
unpopular thoughts and I had a running
bit throughout it where they were
unpopular thoughts and it was like
flavors no but but I I thought it was
too much of a carbon copy of secret time
and it was like the same maybe different
it's like it's like when I go specials
are different but when I go on the road
it is fucking I'm all over the map I do
whatever I want to do I have no rules to
it so I wanna do a special I need to
kind of remember that there are no rules
to it so don't look at something you did
that worked and try to recreate that
this is me and this is me and anyone
I've ever worked with because I am I am
I am a hardcore I believe what you
believe don't talk about where you're
from
the city just go up tell a joke like
I've hammered it into people don't only
hear about the fucking city just told
you on a special when you're in the city
and it's not being taped talk about the
city and you spent the day there and
whatever like I think that's great man
you show specific to the city you're
going to like read to knows I always try
to do a couple by the way here's
something you cannot in a taping this is
two comics for comics you can also do
that in your taping you can do that Iraq
does it by the way correct there were
some shows on this and I don't know what
show we use we shot four shows which I
will always do if not six interesting to
Friday to Saturday and then do you cut
in between them or do you just use one
use one it's the last one always it's
always last one interesting well the
first when you're taping a special we
always tape at least three or four yeah
I usually do sometimes more I had to do
some pre tapes on this one which was
crazy but the first one is always a
camera rehearsal yeah first one is like
the first one that we saw it was a great
show stand-up it's like shooting golf
yeah there were things that were out of
focus and they and not it didn't always
it wasn't the best shot show it was a
the probably was a performance wasn't
the best performance it was a great
performance we have it and we used parts
of it like it was crazy but like for
some reason there was like one joke that
I told that was when I told on the first
show it was like three minutes shorter I
don't know what like it just was I
didn't I didn't stumble or I didn't grab
for things like there was like weird
things like in there that happens but
yeah we use the last show on the second
show we film the second show there's a
mustard stain on my and no one caught it
I said me before I walk out tell me yes
my necklaces yes they're all my cuz I
had it shows with where the st. Jude
miraculous
I'll show my commie central one we only
shot two shows because we didn't have a
lot of money my half of my belly is
showing the entire show which is not who
I am asshole had to fix a lot of it
impose but you can still see like parts
of my belly which is like makes me sweat
stains that why Oh reason I'm sweating
right now
I use the kleiner it's pads which are
like maxi pads that you put inside your
shirts I would I'm no sweating just what
I also have why where these Nicks I wear
shirts under my shirts have maxi pads in
them I would stand when I wore shirts to
do stand-up I would stand with my shirt
before I went onstage and I was like
tell me what I'm gonna go on tell me was
such a fucking pain in the ass tell me
one minute one
soon soon soon soon and then I put it on
and walk out and it's immediately sweat
would show up I when I started taking my
shirt off number one I stopped sweating
entirely wait that's why you take your
shirt off
I took my I would take my shirt off
because I didn't give a fuck it was the
road and I didn't care but you could do
laughs we through the show nope I walk
out rip it off the beginning kill a beer
place to go nuts and then I put it back
on and then I just going back into the
show and then and then at one point I
was in Columbus and I took it off and I
just something happened in the room and
I started going there and I forgot to
put it on yeah and then like 15 minutes
then I go I stole my shirt off it gets a
laugh and I go to put it on his woman
the back goes gave it off oh my god so
then I get offstage and someone I worked
with that I respected was like um hey
men just give you a heads up you just
did a whole show shirtless and I was
like yeah and they're looking you're not
in shape like should be very distracting
but like at some point they forgot about
it some point we're at a barbecue and
you're just killing at a barbecue yeah
and they're like and and so I went
really he's like I don't know but like
if that's gonna be your thing but like
and so the next show I take my shirt off
and now I'm thinking about it you know
yeah like I'm like is this awkward yeah
and then at one point I stopped thinking
about it and it just I did the whole
show shirtless and then I just started
going I feel so I I immediately
subtracted all of the what shirt am I
gonna bring what those do I need to wear
I didn't care about shirts anymore
and I stopped sweating immediately I
second on my shirt comes off I don't
sweat at all and I'm like so much more
calm and then
and now if I were a shirt on stage you
can see me going like inside my shell
like so and so I got afraid of the sweat
shall we I don't I'm not comfortable
when I take my shirt off I am like I
become the Florida kid I was growing up
I am fucking so comfortable with my
shirt off it's ridiculous like I spent
almost the entirety of my childhood
shirtless like up Sultana I only wore a
loincloth and moccasins like that was
all I would wear oh yeah sex gold oh no
a loincloth yeah this is Lord of the
Flies no it was waffle and I was wild
boy and I was waiting for Bigfoot to
show up so yeah oh yeah and then I was
shamed into wearing clothes by my dad
who's like buddy you might want to get
some clothes one of the mall and I was
like done I'm cool he's like you're
gonna be the only one in the loincloth
I'm auxins I was like appropriation or
even allowed to wear moccasins anymore
but back then man knee-high moccasins
and a loincloth you could if you were
looking for me look in a tree that's
where you're gonna find me I mean look
the Scottish had there's something to
that those skirts
oh it's and then speedos when speedos I
will wear speedos like no do still do
you wear briefs where no one where I'm
from Florida you don't wear underwear
never worn underwear I'm from Florida
what yeah no is that a Florida thing I
don't know but I just write it off to be
in from Florida so don't you chase I
don't know I know I wouldn't know it I
don't I don't know what not shaving
feels like your balls hurt no no my dick
everyone always asks the zipper yeah but
it's kind of fun if you asked my toe
do you ever zip your dick in your pants
by accident what's happened you know
more pubic hair pubic hair get zipped
off quite often do you have all pubic
hair by the way I have a joke about I
wonder if I talked about not wearing
underwear am i specify have a joke about
mine is it a common thing that men don't
wear underwear
who wears underwear in here
yes we're sponsored by the Emmys I don't
know I've never I don't wear it
I had an aunt that used to not wear
underwear just jeans with no underwear
yeah it is sickening no it is makes me
physically ill I can't I can't so men
also don't wash their jeans
I can't imagine putting a pair of do you
wash your pants everyday seldomly so you
put the same pair of pants on your bare
dick every day
hashtag patriarchy hashtag we freezer we
put it in the freezer when I'm done
wait how often do you wash your jeans
very seldomly I put them in the freezer
wait what I put my jeans in the freezer
i disinfect them by the way I do know a
guy I do know a guy am I the first one
that tells you this is okay either this
is so fucking Florida or I'm out of my
goddamn mind I do not run where I when
I'm done with my jeans for the day I
then take them off and throw them in the
freezer who taught you that I don't know
technically I do know a guy who hooked
up with a friend of mine who was such a
germaphobe that he made her put her
purse in the freezer before they had
such that's interesting so that's the
only freezer reference point I have no
yeah by genes in fact number two make
them dinner no I don't know if it's a
y-direction your genes if it's a thing
that people in the south do specifically
a lot you're not supposed to wash jeans
every day I understand but if you don't
wear underwear and your anal cavity is
exposed and I'm a sweater ball sweater
like I am definitely like a shower every
day but I just the jeans what people
don't I did a whole episode about this
in the NBC show I made about finding out
that guys don't wash their jeans yes
it's fine if the outside is dirty but if
you're not wearing underwear you cannot
wear the same jeans every day without
cleaning them this is why we have Corona
you never wear underwear never wearable
so if you go on stage your asshole which
has been cleaned by a bidet you know
often giggled at the idea that I go
onstage with basically three articles of
clothes myself like like I been playing
strip poker one time
flip-flops and pants on and I was like
this is gonna be a quick game also hold
on we never finished the bidet
conversation because I still don't
understand how using a Maday reduces the
amount of toilet paper you use so I've
been hands-free for like two years but
then how do you wipe the water off are
you just pat dry like you get a little
pull up everything just pat dry but
you're clean you're dry that thing hoses
shit out of the crow Veen like the like
it like you say you have like a little
bit of like a nugget I feel like you
just made a word out of crevice and
curvy this is why we would have never
worked as a couple because we would have
been at a dinner party I say me and you
just go Praveen it's a new thing my
husband the know it spray hoses the what
the butthole the the wrinkles within the
blood war inside the bottle I let it go
I let it break I have a theory hot take
unpopular opinion unpopular thoughts
that guy's use bidets cuz it feels good
on their balls no it doesn't even touch
my balls
how close are your balls to your
butthole Benton told me like five inches
I'd say like this car this fall not as
close as a vagina in a butthole
this what is between this and that
contain your taint and I'm and I have
like maybe you have a seam on your taint
does it like I think that girls tell you
about the scar yeah and I go I remember
we were like making him bad and I said I
said fee like I'd like a scar there and
she goes yeah that's where God sewed you
up and I went sewed me up and I'm gonna
go in like wait was I born with two
fuckers that's a joke
you know about it while I was like dad
I'll fucking vagina and my parents just
were like we gotta hide your balls yeah
I was like why would they how great
would it be if you had a vagina behind
your balls you could just be like okay
I'm sittin on my dick everybody oh my
god but I remember she was that swear
God so Jeff and I went what he doesn't
need a needle he's God he would've just
it would be it should be like this
but instead it's like it's got a crease
in it I just don't understand how bad
days I don't feel so but here's what I'm
saying I think that you guys as shits
are too viscous and runny and I think my
my poops I won't even call them sheds
they are poops are hard like not hard
hard but they're like one thing and
they're clean pick these fibers there's
no like residue anywhere there's no
residual anything yeah okay so if you're
salt of your poops are a a short song
beginning middle and end I I need love I
found love and now we're in love yeah
mine are like mine are like Freebird
shitting like an a lot of times I'll get
up and I'm not done I'm just give up on
it mine are fucking like polished oh
they look like a quartz crystal when I
shit my ass holes like a bouncer at 2:00
a.m. get stuck in the hair oh does have
it that's why I'm hands-free because
there was a time where toilet paper will
get stuck in the hair you all sudden
you'd white and then it was like that
your hair was going like hold on hold on
grab something then grab it laughter
down you'd be like then you'd be like
what is wrong with my ass and then how
do you wipe front on the front wiper and
no one ever stopped me okay you can
Winnie wipes
that's my front yeah yeah meet you right
now vagina but no but we don't I don't
drag up my body out of there like a
match like I'm from that that's insane
no it doesn't ever go into my hoo-ha you
don't rub it up like ever don't stop
Banting goes from behind so makes no
sense
no no that's a Democrat all we thought
about
yes right he says people stand up in
heaven like squat too white yeah and
then when you stand up your butt house
closing there so poop in there so yeah
but you have to be sitting down but I
just when you sit down your buttholes
closed and when you sit up it opens no
no no no you stand if it closes so all
sometimes I'll sit on the toilet seat
and I'll start one cheek and then pull
the other take over and then plant it so
that my body potty I would get stage
high kiss boots if I could and wear
those all days shit I got my own squatty
potty's you lean forward when you should
lean forward yeah I do lean forward some
of the best shots I've ever taken we're
in in foreign countries where they just
had a hole in the ground oh yeah and
you're like mom oh my god this is
amazing
yeah this is like fucking Serbian
accidents I don't even know that that's
another thing Whitney would call me on
the Serbs never left okay i yeah I I
could I could talk about shitting for
hours I didn't realize that sometimes
when you fart poop particles come out
and gnats wear or maybe not what please
yeah I can't burn Steve Byrne mistaken
well is maybe that's did he burn someone
won't fart in his own pants
someone wants his own pants is he far
down you won't fart his pants it's got
to be Sebastian well cuz Sebastian used
to have the joke that he would fart in a
towel if girls came over you remember
that and then go I wanna smell a dream
see what smells like my Orangina fire I
farted into a McDonald's couple in time
I've brought it over my daughters and I
go girl you never believe this I just
caught a fairy and they're like what
and then like yeah I was wait he would
fall into a talented Lily smell because
his whole thing was used to do this
whole bit about when he was single when
girls would come over he would have
Orangina he had this whole bit about
having Orangina but he was so much fun
to fuck he my guess is Sebastian was so
like such a perfectionist about it and
like germophobic but he was very
specific about who i liked i he didn't I
don't feel like he was like I bet no but
I bet I bet you you meant
you'd be like yeah it's like it's like
more kids you get skittles you put them
in your soda and be like yeah and then
also he goes yeah yeah and next time
you're over there was like would you
like some skittles oh yes no no
Sebastian had game oh I thought you
meant in terms of like sleeping with a
lot of women I feel like he was very
picky oh no he's picky but I mean he was
probably I would swap a hint of
something that happened in your
childhood
and he'd register yep oh yeah oh yeah
yeah yeah next date oh I've got false
thought ahead of the game romantic
Italian also I remember Sebastian was
maybe the only guy when I started the
store that didn't have like riff raff
around showed up did a spot left he's
still like that yep but no girls no
trash I believe that fucked up a lot of
great comic 100% I think pussy is ruined
I wondered percent have seen it happen
it's like and you look and you go oh man
some some guys just got better when they
got married because the prop yes well no
I mean it's like and some of the best
actors too I mean Steve Carell and and
Will Ferrell and all those guys you know
it's like there's a common denominator
because it also focuses you and Oh
having kids was like the biggest I was
like dialed me and go I'm going the
store or I'm gonna store I go to the
Improv in my setting I just go home have
a beer and go home yeah and so I do you
think there's like a couple of our
friends that pretend they're not engaged
or married
[Laughter]
I think there's a couple comics where
it's like write a couple names don't
know why there's a couple comics there's
just like why isn't your girl on your
social media like why are you pretending
to be single the best material is about
being in a relationship and having kids
I just found out Brian has kids like a
month ago like I'm look why don't you
talk about your games you should really
meet them it's hard you know I don't
think I'm not certain but I don't think
Tom hasn't really talked about his kids
yet but it's like it's hard to write the
other night he did something like about
bathing with one of ours yeah yeah he's
got a new bit yeah but he but like it's
hard to write about your kids especially
if you're like a burr or a Rogen who's
always coming
topic first like angle first it's well
they're star
is more talking about big picture like
human nature stuff and yeah like taking
a thing we own apart I think from for me
it was like I'm a storyteller so I
immediately was like my daughter did
this my daughter did that and so it for
me it was very easy yeah to flip in but
I but I was scared because you also you
know that when I was young when I was
young in comedy you didn't want to talk
about having kids it was like a killer
like it would just it would makes you
family guys like give me someone cool
yeah it's about a prank your friend or
talks about some edgy topic give me edgy
totally I remember the first joke I had
about my kids that I that I was like I
remember it was a joy it was a bit
called baby I'll distract where she had
put her finger in her ass and put in the
dog's mouth Segura and Ian bagg yes I
don't like that bit is fucking legit
funny like it's not it's not a Family
Guy joke it's legit I don't really and
they're like dude the way you talk about
your kids in this and then by the way I
got married to this like honesty of my
kids I'm not like because a lot of dads
would go up and go I got a son
it's fucking guys a badass dude he's
gonna be fucking you know and it was
just it was like no one wanted to hear
about yeah no one wants to hear about a
comic with a big dick they want to hear
about oh yeah
and so when I started that when I told
him my night that story I could I then
was like I could just make these two who
they are like these two characters in my
life were fucking yeah goofballs and I
was like Louie CK I mean when he really
slapped was when that that bit about
calling his kids cunts stops you from
getting it what would you call someone
who refused to put their shoes on if you
were sitting at the door the joke that
made me the my favorite louis c.k joke
about having kids I'm not gonna word it
right but he goes his jokes just for
parents you're not feeling when you put
your second kid in the car seat and you
walk from the car you know that feeling
that was like so yeah dialed in to like
I knew that feeling of going like
finally a fucking second for me and
having two daughters when he had that
bit about I didn't have kids this is
when it was like oh this is cracking
because I don't have kids I can't really
relate to it but it was so fucking funny
about how he's like boys will
ruin your stuff and girls will ruin your
brain yeah and one of his daughters
Barbie dolls broke and she said will you
break my sisters so we're even
oh and he's like and I did it you had to
break the head off of a doll Louie
Louie's still I think I think there's
new special if he does one or if well
yeah I think it's gonna be fuckin
groundbreaking and he's someone that I
you
I studied watching specials Byrne and
Louie are like two of my favorites to
watch specials of and Chappelle I think
she pals fucking genius
thank spells one of the greatest comics
that's ever lived his kick her in the
pussy story was a game changer for me
that was like that was when I heard that
joke I was getting ready to sue your
time I was like that's the fuck you mean
everyone needs to kick her in the pussy
joke that's the fucking that's the art
form the art form is is sometimes
misdirection some yes that's right
it's so surprised it's so hard to
surprise people anymore to die or shock
people yeah and it because of what the
news is shock shock shock all day long
so it makes it even harder for us I
can't wait did you seen or McDonald's
coronavirus set no I saw the picture
yeah he did a whole settle in the
coronavirus wow he did a he posted a
tweet where he said you know doing comm
me doing comedy right now would make
people sick also the corona virus is out
there and I don't want anyone to get
back to me the other day because you're
gonna do the work so the lineup was so
fucking sick the lineup was so sick this
was a show that was gonna do on st.
Patrick's Day for his special we're a
bunch of us we're gonna go at like 11:00
a.m. and do standard you see this I see
this very there's probably the first
thing I ever did that really like move
the needle for me was I do this Collin
sector work shows where I go in I do
radio I drink on radio I go right to the
club and I do a morning show at like
10:00 a.m. doors are open at 9:00 people
get fucking
wasted and we just do this really
impromptu fun comedy show open mic like
kids from the in the in whatever city I
was in would always step in and get
onstage it was really really fun and
then we'd stay there and drink all day
long the ones at Columbus were so
legendary but I did like Columbus three
years or oh I think DC I did so we're
gonna do it I released tickets through
my
my community app my my phone number
three two three two oh eight oh eight
four four I just released him through
there it sold out remember when I got
you that number you guys really what the
fuck is this Mia tombow three shitting
on him I love it I was in I was in some
place in New Mexico my text on my where
do I go eat I use it all the time okay
it was a fucking game changer when we
had to cancel shows for Corona because I
was able to text everyone just in
Detroit and go hey guys this is getting
cancelled I want you to know right now
here's how yeah and so and so and so I
didn't want to release the lineup
because it the lineup wasn't important
to me because that what should be
important to you is coming up for st.
Patty's Day at the store all day it was
gonna be and there's so few surprises in
life anymore what an amazing surprise to
not know the lineup of us what an
amazing surprise to get a $40 ticket
which is a high priced ticket yeah to
get a $40 take 150 if you wanted a VIP
and then we're gonna have shows I can
say the lineup now because it's not
gonna happen
maybe it gets rescheduled but it won't
be the same land up so you don't know
but it was like me you bill burr segura
Jim Jefferies
Norman Donald it was everyone I wanted
he and stand up by the way I'm by the
way Sebastian D'Elia
by the way during the day during the day
noon it was gonna be such a Bobby this
is just the stand-up we're gonna do 15
stand ups more if you want more like a
live podcast version of it or something
maybe not doing stream we're gonna do
podcasts in the Oro is gonna be tiger
belly and bill burt were the two podcast
in the oh are you could see all this the
via the belly room was turned into a VIP
lounge where there would be a live
stream to either or where you could
switch the channels and go back and
forth we had taco trucks Kogi taco
trucks my buddy Roy Choi his tiger talks
were gonna be in the parking lot it was
gonna be open who's gonna be the funnest
fuckin time and I was like didn't want
to release me I wanted people to be
rewarded for believing that it was gonna
be a good show
yeah yeah yeah it's like it's like not
to say you're fans but like my fans
where they go if he's just burped I'm
excited yeah yeah yeah when they see
that the fucking lineup like David Spade
was gonna try to stop by and then and he
was like texted he goes all I'm shooting
like the people that were hitting me up
to do it Oh like I hit up day I hit up
everyone to do it yeah but it was gonna
be such a fucking great lineup and now
I'm so bummed because I was gonna do
that and then and then I had all these
plans and now you know with I'm looking
want everyone to be safe obvious thing
before I let you go I do want to talk
through this because I think it is
interesting to people because a couple
things like you know when this these
cancellations start happening it was
kind of interesting because I believe
[Laughter]
cancelled you call you text amigo are
you canceling your shows and I was like
what no no what are you talking about I
remember looking your Instagram you're
like you're on a plane with a with like
a burqa on and sanitizer everywhere and
I was like and then you started texting
me I ever heard I was getting cancelled
and then and then all of a sudden
started becoming real and I was like I
was like no fucking way I was already in
New Orleans and now I was already in New
Orleans I had been having a great
morning we went out they drinkin yeah
getting ready to take a nap
and and then it got very real and Tom
called me it texted me and he's like
he's like hey you're still doing your
shows because I cancelled next week and
I went huh this every hour things were
changing so you and I were texting on
Wednesday and I was like because when
Tuesday's when festival started
canceling Pearl Jam Coachella that sort
of thing and I talked to my agents and
they were like mmm that's an insurance
thing that's different yeah right that's
an insurance thing so by Tuesday night
it was like okay tours are only
canceling if there's a big insurance
liability sort of such places where kids
would be or older people would be and
then people that had maybe older
audiences were canceling and then people
who weren't moving tickets anyway that
was the other one was like hey guy okay
yeah well if I only sold 2,000 people
coming to see me totally so and then it
was like okay what if we just cancelled
meet-and-greets yeah which is to me I
already started going that sucks like
people aren't going to get their picture
this is already a little bit like
they're getting boned
aiyla a week before when I was in I did
mad I did a Medford something I did
Schenectady bulks Berg Schenectady
Connect today I don't even know that
mean that's the guy lost my virginity to
was from a place called Schenectady and
I kept forgetting where he was from and
he goes skin neck titty is connected
oh well yeah I did wolfberry Schenectady
two shows of The Beacon two shows at
constitutional right to though just to
put in perspective those are the
Constitution halls like thirty nine
hundred and so ila my youngest called me
when I was going to wilkes-barre and she
said hey big boy no mean greets and I go
I go baby I gotta do mean grits that's
part of my things I was doing mean
greeting then I go out to the to the
bars I tell everyone you want to get a
picture me in a bar get a pin come out
say hi all I say is selfie mode
landscape that's it that's it and ila
goes no and she goes listen it was
really insightful she goes I'm worried
you're gonna get sick if anyone's gonna
get this disease it's gonna be you
because you're meeting so many people
that's right so she goes please just
don't do meeting greets and I go baby
she just please do it for me so I didn't
I did him meet-and-greet in wilkes-barre
disconnected he and she called and she
had my cousin a band posted a picture
and she said you went to a bar last
night like you told me we're going to
bars dad please don't do this and then
she said dad this is irresponsible
because think of the last person that
takes a picture with you
you're gonna give it to everyone as soon
as you get it you give me it to everyone
yeah and you're gonna survive it you're
healthy yes fucking I love this is the
kid I make fun of more than anyone on
any special I call a window looking
mouth-breather on she and so I didn't do
it in Schenectady I didn't do it as
beacon and more people disappointed very
very bad point it's like they're not
getting their money's and I still didn't
get it and then when I did the second
show at Constitution Hall
her people and by the way I know that
this isn't it is just responsibility on
the second show and we're just hearing
Inklings about this this virus going
around it's not as crazy as about what's
going on in Italy and yeah but it's
still like doesn't seem like it's gonna
get here mm-hmm and by the way cases
that was also yes there were no cases
yet because there also no tests to
diagnose cases so that's why there were
no cases and also it was kind of like
it's the flu and because it was like la
New York and Tom Hanks had it our
conversation on like Tuesday Wednesday
was like Oh
this is gonna seem like to Americans
that this is like lib tardes
oversensitive lib tardes who are sense
this is like a Hollywood New York LA I I
definitely felt like the show must go on
yes gonna be fine comedy we we the show
must go on when everyone else pussies
out were the Warriors that fucking show
up and when I did when I and I by the
way I went to the Knicks game I went to
Madison Square Garden I was like I was
like I'm gonna be fun we're gonna be
fine we're gonna get through this
you single handedly constant do not
check my routing in the coronavirus I
thought every one of my boss got
coronavirus at one point I was obsessed
with the bars I'm so OCD about shit yeah
I've been washing my hands more than
ever my feets in almost Howard Hughes
this one and so when we did the same
Constitution Hall I heard a dude
coughing and I thought to myself I
thought that's the first time I got off
stage and I went oh if if that guy had
coronavirus and by the way it was not
there yet yeah it hadn't been in but
what I thought next week I remember
thinking I got went back to the room I
go oh this coronavirus thing is gonna be
very real it's gonna affect our touring
and they're like no alone I go no no no
because we are asking and this is why I
was comfortable cancelling we're asking
people to do to laugh which is really
expelling air shoulder-to-shoulder with
complete strangers and so we will spread
it it'll spread to the entire that's
right it'll spread to the entire theater
and now we're talking and then I did the
numbers and I whatever shows I had I had
8,000 so I told over 8,000 tickets and I
went oh I'm I'm I will almost guarantee
I will give it to at least 4,000 people
if I do shows easily and so I talked and
but I hadn't realized that until five
o'clock on Wednesday Thursday Thursday
yeah that's right in New Orleans it's
Wednesday night you texted me and I was
like no I'm getting on a fucking plane
what are you talking about well I
started panicking because not everyone
was actually doing it but I got I got to
text
that changed the way that I thought
because I was getting a checking that my
community number the texting number and
people run please tell me you're coming
please tell me we were getting text and
we check our comments I mean I
shamelessly do I don't have I think
that's a good thing and people were like
I've been planning this for four months
and I got these tickets for my wife and
please don't know drove I drove all the
way from Lubbock that's right oh my god
god I just got a hotel room dude yes
people were standing outside my bus
yelling at me and I all I thought was
it's not like I'm cool with overreacting
yeah I'm not cool with under with being
an idiot like and by the way I'm also
cool with this airing a month from now
yeah and this whole thing being a hoax
thing no no no but I mean no but I mean
like this being on the Internet in a
month oh yeah yeah and I'm very cool if
this coronavirus thing was not as bad as
we thought it was and everyone and it's
such that because I would not be cool
with being on here going not did my
shows dude it's a fucking it out flu
wash your fucking it I don't know that
I'm not a doctor all I know is that I'm
in a room with a ton of people making
them breathe really hard and then that's
my goal and I wouldn't be I would not be
cool with it I'm fucking 30 feet from
the closest person yeah they're all
giving it to each other and here's two
things changed my mind which is I got to
I got a text where a girl said I'm
immunocompromised
I cannot come to your show please come
back soon and she sent me this whole
thing
another text I got said I live with my
grandmother so I can't come to your show
and then I got a comment when I did the
photo with the mask saying I'm coming
Detroit it's not canceled some comment
just said God how greedy can you be and
I was like oh my god it the tables are
starting to turn it what what what
yesterday was honorable that we're gonna
show up and fight through this is now
being perceived as selfish and greedy
yeah and this is what Benton said
because I was like we got to show up for
people like we got to go we sold these
tickets and he goes if you go they're
gonna come so it's up to you to stop
this I when I when I cancel the shows I
thought I felt an immense amount of
depression it's like and I by the way
felt it all week driving across country
because I just was like this this is not
like I have this is not what I do I want
to perform that's all I want to do is
stand up that's it and then I went to
the theater in New Orleans and it's such
a fucking gorgeous theater I was like
I'm not getting the opportunity to
perform here tonight and it also by the
way wasn't in New Orleans yet remember
the conversation you and I had was I was
going to Detroit in Houston and I was
like dude I'm going to places they have
it
New Orleans doesn't have it yet so maybe
you should i but i but i was also going
to alabama i guess a case that broke out
in alabama and and all I was like and
then I'm just like this isn't cancelled
and I got a lot of shit you didn't
cancel you reschedule or reschedule some
people were going on yeah we're gonna
post him you and I were very um I think
sort of put off by what the way a lot of
people were just canceling without
putting a rescheduled date up what's
wrong you okay senator for Disease
Control and Prevention recommends no
gatherings of 50 or more people in the
US for the next eight weeks okay so
we're gonna be doing a little more
reschedule I hope
we're gonna be a lot of podcasting I
want to hope that what I just read is
now disproved that this airs whatever
tomorrow the next day that is just
proved I'm not a doctor all I can do is
go all I can do is go I can only do the
best where I can sleep at night yeah and
and just like I was very cognizant I got
invited to a fraternity party in Las
Cruces in Matt New Mexico recently yeah
there's a TOS there's my 30-day I was
driving through and they found me there
my boss if you wanna come to our
fraternity party you have some white
claw
and I was like I was like fuck yeah man
that's what I'm and then I that's what
I'm about like I like that shit with a
bunch of kids and having a few beers
pressure I can't do it I was like I
can't cuz it I don't know I don't I
don't know actually
unethical at this point to congregate in
big groups like it's wrong I mean is
morally wrong I mean even like when I
see you and I go to give you a hug it's
what I normally do I go fuck am I
supposed to hug you and like yeah and
and so I
no I know I'm overthinking it but I'm
not I don't think so I don't think it's
possible to overthink this situation
based on what happens in Italy because
we're on the same trajectory and we have
about the same level of preparedness
which is very little yeah and we're not
China it we're not a communist country
you can't unless you enforce martial law
you can't make people stay in their
homes like the way they can in China it
worked in China but we don't have the
same ability to control people like that
there's a democracy it's uh it's gonna
be um it's gonna I think it'll be a
fucking it'll be interesting to see what
happens it's a doozy and it's also I
think you know look comics we are about
showing up and we're about going to the
places that nobody else will go and like
oafish Lee yes no face-to-face
interaction with our fans like this is
what we do but I think a lot of people
were canceling without rescheduled dates
and something that I think is important
that everybody knows through this is we
also I could not reschedule Detroit or
Houston especially until there was a
state of emergency declared because in
the contracts that we sign it's called
force majeure so if I'm supposed to go
to Detroit tomorrow and I cancel I'm on
the hook for that and you don't get your
money back
the theaters not gonna refund your
tickets right it's a real shit it's it's
a lot more complicated than us just
cancelling yes yes so a lot of people
were saying to me why the fuck aren't
you just cancelling I'm like because I
have a contract that means the people
that bought tickets don't get their
money back until a state of emergency is
declared it's called an act of God so
otherwise people will just fucking
cancel shows all the time you know and
then the union workers in the theaters
you know they have certain things and
they have to get paid regardless so
you're boning the theater we also
there's a couple promotion companies
that we work with and we fuck up our
relationship with them I'll tell you
what was really the this was the only
like the only thing I could hang my hat
on for this because I just I just pulled
into LA today I've been driving from New
Orleans to LA noire to my tour bus and
the thing that this is the thing that
made me feel better is I cancelled I'd
stayed almost stayed offline the past
couple days not entirely but just like
definitely the first day I cancelled I
posted a written statement and I was
like I got to do this yeah great I read
the comments and the comments were all
very very Pau
they're like thank you you're doing the
right thing not a lot of people in New
Orleans were saying that but so but they
were like you know a niche pussy and
then I wouldn't theater and I got really
bummed and I looked at the theaters this
Hsiang Hsiang Hsiang Hsiang earthing
theater angler yeah and it was gorgeous
and then I looked at the ushers who were
in there and they were all a little
older and I thought wow I thought I
wonder if I just obviously I don't I'm
always gonna be devil's advocate and go
Bert nothing was gonna happen nothing
was gonna happen you overreacted you're
being a fucking pussy that's how my
brain goes my brain says but then I go
got man
there was like legit you look at those
theaters a lot of the ushers are older
that's how they make their money and I
don't and you would have just
annihilated that hole rolling rolling
rolling
I got me on these thongs and they are my
favorite underwear did I not tell you
this when we were not rolling you did
tell me that I think the thong out by
the way Oh cute I ordered that oh you
gave me a sassy little portable number
remember the last how about your
underwear how that way I don't remember
we talked about it on here you've shamed
me in from all these people are firing
you granny panties oh that's right the
full but ones that was sickening that
was perverted into that me undies here's
the thing about thongs that people don't
understand and underwear in general is
that they move and they chafe and they
do all me undies
the ones I have they just stay right
where you put them a second skin
they don't wedgie up into your crevices
I love my immunity I know I'm honestly
these I never buy new underwear this is
my didn't I ask you to order me more
okay better than putting on your me
undies your wig you two this is woman's
month which should be every month
honestly and it is me undies mission to
motivate all the women around them to
embrace and show up as their full
unfiltered self Mandie's believe
self-expression is so powerful and that
they want to encourage all women to live
that way every day
mandis thinks you're heroic just as you
are okay no no me and ease has a great
offer for my listeners for any
first-time purchasers get 15% off and
free shipping honestly I will give you
your money back at this point that's how
confident I am that you are going to
like these
100% satisfaction guarantee makes me
feel even more comfortable offering that
to get your 15 percent off your first
pair of free shipping and 100%
satisfaction guarantee ah go to me
undies comm slash Whitney that's me
undies comm / Whitney I'm wearing them
right now and my butt feels great when
you see me what's the first thing you
think stay away but also what gorgeous
beautiful here I go to your eyebrows for
know how I got that way yeah I wash them
with functional beauty you're obsessed
with this brand
they're fine you went and made your own
shampoo where's you tell me what you
need you could be the color or no color
if you don't like color and your own
smell and everything yeah don't smell
it's that's fun that's fine it's oh it's
also the Internet's top-rated customized
hair brand oh geez
thirty thousand five star customer
reviews you're not special Benton
everyone loves this yeah
so you had to take a quiz for questions
and they make a customized shampoo
you're the needs vegan and crosses are
for your knees to wash that hair on your
knees vegan and cruelty free you know we
love that no sulfates parabens fat
deletes the phthalates mineral oils or
other harmful ingredients what flavor
did you pick I think I did the apple
pear juicy pear oh yes we dead you dead
like I'm a layer mask I did a yellow and
a lavender Oh fresh frog launch
countryside decorated right now okay
nice Whitney take your four part hair
profile quiz and save 20% on your first
order don't spend another minute in hair
misery go to function of beauty calm /
Whitney let them know we sent you
that's function of beauty calm / Whitney
yellow and purple juicy pear
[Music]
when I got I got a series on Netflix
that we shot they're gonna be out ya
know it should be coming out soon it's
called the cabin but what I think we'll
change it to comedians in the cabin
getting cancelled comedians and cabins
getting corona me and crystalline
episode and we I Kris and I this is
gonna sound weird we're both pretty
clear about when we think we're doing
well at something of them or not we left
that shoot being so insecure that we
weren't funny guys were fucking
hilarious
we disagree we we go to the hardest I've
ever left we go to Bert's show he's
doing this great idea or comedians come
to a cabin and they do create I don't
wanna give any of it away I tell you
exactly Bobby Lee gave me an enema crisp
oh yeah okay and give me a coffee enema
and it and he didn't have the valve
right and it squirted out of the thing
and he thought I shit all over him it
was dude it and then I shit and then I
did shit all over all shit he gave me a
nun and I shit all over him and it was
so neat you know is yours is better
because it's words be Bobby and Donnell
is just action with I've ever laughed is
were so panicked about Chris said to
Whitney said some about good give you a
hundred dollars and she goes don't link
anyone what she goes it looks creepy
when you ain't by the way I'm giving
away the funniest part of the show but
this is I mean drive still giggle at
this and he goes it's not creepy when I
awake she goes it's very creepy when you
ain't Chris and I go do it to me and he
said something to me and I said and I
went okay that's creepy I go wait
Whitney tell me if it tell me if it's
creepy when I do it to you and I go
you've got cancer and Wiest and so now
we start laughing at what's the worst
news you're gonna deliver to someone but
but but sell it with a wink it's me
Chris and Whitney doing this delivering
hate news and we're laughing yeah it's
inoperable and we are laughing so hard
and poor Leah Remini is just sitting
there going I don't know what the fuck
to do Leah Remini was like I think I
need to go home I think I'm gonna leave
because what would happen is the three
of us would start in on a small bit that
we found hilarious it's like this is
dark she's like this isn't funny
this is dark and I was in Scientology
yeah but that was the fun there was that
she was so fucking funny and I just got
a I just got the my lawyer sent to me
he's like hey there's a clause where
you've got to prove all nudity and I was
like oh are we naked I was in every
single episode at full frontal nudity
and at one point I said to a girl I said
to a young lady who is our camera op or
assistant camera I feel like a lot of
guys are struggling with this girl vs.
young lady vs. woman she was a young
lady but what's the difference in girl
in young lady did you find yourself
correcting herself girl yeah I did
because girl for me as I feel it's
condescending ah when you work with
someone girl me I take it as a
compliment it makes me feel young she
wasn't a woman woman for me as like
there was this woman I work with woman
also imply I do you even need to have
the age involved at all like no one
would say like I was working with this
young man the other day this guy this
this chick somebody knows what to do a
man know this so this will whistle tart
[Laughter]
this is a piece of comes up to me she
was the she was a young lady I would
imagine she's 27 my consist I still can
say that a young lady and Shh I'm naked
on a floor and I'm drinking wine and she
has her head turned and I said I
apologize by the way every time I got
any butt-naked I was so over correct I
was like guys I'm getting naked everyone
know this please leave the room
so she got her head turned and I say to
her I said hey when you signed up for
this today like did they have you like
signed some sort of clause like going
like I'm aware there will be nudity or
she goes no and I went wait what did
they tell you this show was she goes I
was told this was comedians in cars
getting coffee
and I said really she goes yeah by the
way her heads turn to be stalking me she
goes yeah this is not what I signed up
for I just did a movie and there was a
girl there was a PA that was on your
show she goes oh yeah I know I met you
I'm Bert Sean US ago yeah how was it she
was like it was intense it was it really
was intense she was like that was
intense
they had a they had a code there was an
another Aussie a woman I can't remember
her name she was she did script so she
wrote whatever was the action was yeah
she was a script supervisor and she had
a shorthand of cock to Camrose CTC so
she just it was like talk to camera
which means your cock to camera and it's
not a big cock it's like they're not
gonna pixelate it at all do you really
do you really think you don't have a big
deck or you're just saying that no like
I have a good dick hard like I have a
legit good dick hard but it is not
impressive soft it is not representative
mark a lot of guys and I don't know if
it's like guys version of
self-deprecation like Howard talks about
his dick not being boy I think is you
truly think I think Howard Stern has a
small dick do you know he's honest about
the way he talks about it only guys with
small dicks would know like I think he's
got a good dick hard but I think when
he's naked with his dick not hard it's
just by the way that look is
representative of you with your dick no
one ever sees your dick hard lists are
dating you I was going to say what was
offed yeah I don't think I've ever seen
anyone's dick soft no you about this
you've never seen a dick that hasn't
been provider it's just flattering
myself every day I see it's hard right
away that's not what I meant
I just mean the guys that I've dated
they think guys the same way girl I
always hide my butt when I walk away
like if I walk away every so if I'm
naked and I walk away from the bed I'll
cover my butt with my hands because I'm
so insecure about like cellulite and
girls do that or the front like because
your thigh jiggle you sort of find ways
to cover it up right and so I find every
guy I've ever dated when they get out of
bed if their dick is not hard which it
wouldn't be they always like hide it
guys usually cover them
I had sex with you you can see my dick
anyway any any from any Angus you're
like you know what I'm capable you know
what I'm capable of
look this isn't us this is you make it
rain
this isn't yeah III I don't have any
problem and I think I did I joke about
it but like my dick doesn't look my with
my body now I just does that's why I'm
not drinking this month and I'm losing
weight and I'm getting my shit together
have you ever shaved your boss oh yeah
I'll take it to the next level when I
was probably like am i when I was when I
was hooking up with chicks which I never
really did a ton of cannot picture it I
did a thing where I trimmed down all my
pubic hair to like a four right with Ed
with beard trimmers before then I took a
magic marker and I drew a sunrise of the
head of the know the Sun like squid like
Dennis Rodman's tattoo sunrise then I
trimmed with a pair of liners all the
hair didn't have marking on it then I
washed it off and it was a fucking
sunrise above my junk it was goddamn
glorious it was like I remember a girl
was lucky enough to see it at that point
she went she went yeah because there's I
wasn't I wasn't like a big like I just
didn't fuck a lot but there's a girl's
ACOG when she saw her like this she went
what is that no and you're like it's
going hold on she said could you do that
to me I go I could do that to anybody
wait I what is the thing about shaving a
woman's pubes I would never let someone
then do that to me oh this is a great
carpet I have done that til the end as
long as we were married I have to go it
is it gets me excited because I know
then we're fooling around she'll say
that's one of the boy hey big boy I
think someone needs a trim and you're
like oh yeah with it was a razor I use
the lawnmower three-point oh I'm sorry
it's maybe the best if you guys are of a
sponsor this is the best fucking piece
of tools I've ever used
they've got the skin-safe technology
where you don't clip you don't cut
because if you use liners like legit
liners you're gonna grab skin don't even
know what a liner is liners are what
black dudes used to trim their beards
they're like they're really really like
I mean like almost like I trim like like
this with Milo it's like a little
straight line that yes it's like that
and they're a little wider okay
cannot use like straight up hair
clippers yeah that is like a like oh
that is like a butcher down there and
you can't use beard trimmers because
that grabs skin so you'll get up
definitely cutter before a deadly cutter
but these fucking lawnmower 3.0 what's
great is sometimes with in depending on
the lighting you can't get a great thing
it's got an LED light right above the
Clippers so you see exactly what you're
cutting now what I do personally I'm
sweating I'm so upset if you want to
talk about my exact I can't breathe I
first of all just get rid of everything
everything long let's just trim it down
let's get everything long we're gonna
leave the top
cuz I've ignored the top altogether like
we're talking pubis part and then I will
the top like has been the closest to the
belly button area like like the like so
if she's laying on the bed like this
okay right okay and then feet up I'll
were feet up I'm gonna get a good angle
with I'm not gonna I'm not gonna what
are you how are you gonna do this with
your legs cross and I got a guess at it
and fight in there you mean you do like
the lips oh yeah stressed out
oh yeah that is sick you're home sick
this isn't an animal on the table then
get him out there
I need her today she won't do it to me
but I just
here's I'm gonna say something very it
doesn't get me a lot of trouble good I
just
I know vaginas are beautiful I know
they're powerful beautiful tulips
Georgia O'Keefe the whole thing I mean
do you really want to be that close to a
vagina oh I like being inside them I
know but to see don't you I mean I won't
worry there'll be like an ingrown no no
no we've been doing this for 18 years
now like I fully bald no no no I like I
like a little I like some tuft I like
hair up top there okay but but not you
can't it's his very problem problematic
is you can't have the the like right
here right on the edge of the valley you
got to trim that back because if you go
down there and it's too long it'll get
you're still going down on the end every
fucking time it is my favorite thing in
the world to do it's like oh and I and I
have gotten that's why I look at Owen
great I've gotten to the place where I
go hold on let's not go out this like
we're starving we haven't had a meal in
a while let's make it like we're not
that hungry and we want to work at the
meal I've gotten so good lately that I
that I that and I wasn't as good I like
at all I used to I read it something in
Playboy when I was like in ninth grade
and I'm it was the wrong thing to read
only men wrote that magazine yeah and
then I and then I watched cathouse and
some girl wins cathouse it was a show on
HBO that Dennis HOF I had like a porn
not a porn house a whorehouse sounds bad
but yeah where else and a brothel that's
a whorehouse even the whores in there
like Jesus Burton fucking called a
brothel god damn it
he had a whorehouse so the house indexes
so and there was this girl who's
teaching a guy had to go down on her
okay and and I was listening to it and I
thought this is so silly
this is now you do it at all entirely
and go home so and so then I was like
wait maybe I'll try her what she said
and that I literally was like I'm gonna
try what she said which was what she
said
basically the whittle it down was gentle
chaos okay until flicking and then
sometimes around but then but always
keep her guessing never like and then
very gentle and but feel her rhythms and
then try to match your speed with her
rhythms and then build to the end or
rhythm body like like her breathing
moving I was like I was like Chris like
you can tell when the woman's getting
closer you're like okay now we can go a
little faster but if you go in super
fast you can then get it's almost like a
helicopter can't fly it too fast or it
falls out of the air ya know we just
learned that ya know we know so so then
I went upstairs we had just had ila so
this is probably thirteen thirteen years
ago and I go upstairs we lived in an
apartment I'm gonna start fooling around
then I go down there and she was like
she's like I know you don't have to that
I was like no I like it
and I I'm who everyone I first did the
first thing I heard her go whoa
and I went oh my god and then I kept
doing it and it happens so immediately I
was like oh and she goes what the fuck
did you just do and I go I don't know
she was like wait that's not what you
normally do where did you work where did
you learn this
nope I just are sold on TV show and I
tried it she was like that fucking works
again and I was like right now it's like
immediately and I was like oh my god and
I I mean it's one of my favorite like I
really enjoy it because I feel like it's
a it sounds super silly but like when
you talk about porn that you watch this
type of porn I watch a lot of times
we'll be POV from a guy down there
because that's the thing that turns me
on
hi by the way I'm sure Leanne will be so
uncomfortable with me she'll wait why
the fuck would you tell people you shave
my vagina I'm like oh sorry I just feel
like with guys and going down on women
like it's so interesting because I feel
like once you figure out what how one
woman is into it I've often wondered you
think that's every woman every woman's
vagina is drastically different I've
often wondered that I like the first
time a guy will do it I'll go okay
I now know what
X's into I know her very intimately I
now know everything about this woman
but now let's like regroup the buttons
are completely different everything's
different so please stop choking me I
had sex with a sick one one time one of
my six and we ended up dating and we're
having sex and it's getting close to
things skills oh yeah you can come on my
face and I was like I wasn't planning on
it but now I'm guessing every guys come
on your face and I was like a fucking
fool if I don't I was like sure why are
guys so into that dude I have no idea it
makes no sense is it just like guys that
are in the Zapruder film but also here's
what I'll say if you're gonna do it
don't miss and make me have to bob and
weave and catch it until you don't make
me have to be like it's embarrassing if
you miss yeah or and if you don't
sometimes I stop my thing and land does
not devily lien can't wrap her head
around something like that yeah what and
then wake up my head stuck to a pillow
no so yeah I know I don't know yeah I'm
sure a lot on this play don't wear
underwear shave my balls love a bad day
good day look love on Grey's cock you
use a bidet but don't wear underwear it
just does not matter the first time I
used a bidet in Japan I enjoyed it so
much that I found myself sitting on the
toilet and letting it hit my ass just
like almost the same way you'd get in a
hot bath because it was warm water and I
just was like this is this is gonna get
even crazier is that do the same people
that are like bidets into eating ass I
don't know I am firmly anti ass eating I
and I know that's that's polarizing but
I think we over we're over glorifying it
at the moment and shaming people that
aren't into it
I think ass eating is like doing shots
do it what like three times a year yeah
when you have nothing to lose do it when
you're going fucking crazy you know when
you're going through a divorce I'm
getting fucking into this but I I've
done it before but it's not it's not
something that I like yeah only do it on
your birthday yeah I don't know you
don't need to ask you're a bitch it's
like Jesus
around forever really oh I've heard that
about people who don't need a sign I
just something I don't really care is if
it gave someone pleasure I'd do it but
I'd its I don't really care and I'm not
I just put needle heads up I mean I just
that preparation anything I just need a
heads up because I don't want to then be
insecure and being like well home let's
I just I just get some baby path like I
just like talks I really still think you
should shoot a porn with that robot doll
you know what that I'm telling you and
then now that we're quarantined I got
nothing but I directed you Jo I will
definitely do you think you can do it I
don't know leave that cheating but with
me anything I wanted I wanted to do I'll
tell you off fair I wanted to do
something with Leanne and she was just
not she's not into it at all but uh no I
I think Lee Novi cooled me fucking a
robot with my face on it
now had sex with a fleshlight before
when I was in Miami right but wait did
you just call it sex right when I
started doing rogan and I remember
leaving his house it was at one time and
he was like he was like KD when a
flashlight and I was like I don't think
so and he's like they're not that bad I
went really and he goes is pretty
fucking awesome I was like wait do you
want his no no no no no they're here
used to be sponsored by
oh it was like we have to cut that out
we know he had and then and then he was
like and then I was like ah sure and
then he then he went to go grab and he's
like oh shit I don't have any I don't
have one or it was what idea that good
my no I think he only had alien ones
left
he was like they're kind of fucking
creepy it was like alien buttholes
and so I think I can't remember totally
but I didn't end up getting one from him
and then I go to Miami and I was like
and I'm walking around Miami and I'm
going to get lunch and then a sex tour
right by the thing and I was like
whorehouse no no sex tour and so I was
like I was like I wonder if they've got
flashlights and so I walk in very
casually and I'm like mmm guys like fun
things like I help you I go you just
have my buddies saying like there's a
thing called a flush like the guys like
now I don't oh okay he goes but we got
fucking a can and I was like I'll take
it I'm sorry it was a can of sapporo
right it was a Sapporo beer can like a
it's like camouflage it was yeah so that
you could keep it your room they would
just think they were just think you were
an alcoholic a bad one well but dad's
drinking problem has gotten to the next
level he's fucking these here why does
your beer smell like pussy
so the Sapporo beer can and I don't by
the way I get it I buy it I panicked buy
it he's like he's like do you want Lube
I was like no I'm gonna rape it yeah
fucking boob you kidding me you know raw
dog it and burn my dick I go yeah give
me Lube and he's like couple travel
packets I go the economy one so I take
it back I race but I don't even eat
lunch I raced back to my room I go to
get I'm like shaky any guy will
understand the feeling of like when
you're excited to jerk off and you're
almost like okay okay take a breath
right now unwrap it open the top and
it's not a vagina it's lips and it
doesn't even look like a woman's lips it
looks like just a dude like oh dude
don't do this please don't do this
please please please hurt hold me oh
come on man pretty seriously seriously
so I
it's like a man with lockjaw and then
I'd leave it in the corner of the hotel
room walking it was it tight I don't it
was it was kind of but not like not like
a person - yeah but like it was alright
those things were okay they were fine
like the first time they were great the
second time you're like I thought this
felt better and then the third time
you're like I think I'm done using this
the doctor you can give to clean it out
do that's the rough part cleaning it out
is like getting rid of a body like
fucking running water through it it's
ballooning up you're like no fuck that
with tears oh my god
yeah I know I was like I can't take it
home I was like I'll leave it for the
maid that's the that's the thing with
with the sex robot is apt to have sex
with her you have to put her in the
bathtub and cleaner with her together
like the Memoirs of a Geisha you just
yeah you just put English Patient and
members who gave me where is your robot
she's well her head is downstairs she's
about to get she just got new eyebrows
she's about to go get a tuneup and then
her body actually I was doing a movie
and they might use her body in it
because it has to be so we're getting a
new body also the new frozen is darker
than I thought it would good what show
is that it's a new you know what I'm
talking about
onward oh yeah that's a Disney or it's
like an animated I want to do the same
movie but with me and my friends and all
we get is my buddy's dick and it's
running in the strip club I think you
want Callens dick
oh god oh this has been a fucking great
pug I know I need to get you out of here
but I never want to stop talking okay
where's your wife and child
I don't know it's 6:30 okay we left text
us when you're done and I'll come back
and get you where are they
um I'll text her she should probably
start heading now
and then we'll do like 50 more Commedia
just texted me hey are you doing any
stand up a comida successful comedian
just texted me this hey Katie hey voice
texting can you not talk hey can you
please pick me up and do some standup
Lien's
Leeanne sense of humor is not good on
stage Brendan Schaub just sent me a text
saying comedians all they do is send me
shit I already fucking know CDC
recommends no events of more than 50
people for the next eight weeks yeah I
told you dumbass yeah that's what I said
okay so Brendan let's just talk some
shit until your wife gets here let's
talk some shit about our friends Brendan
here's the problem with some of these
pie you podcast famous podcasters is
that the no one is in the room to tell
you when you're wrong about things
oh that's why I stopped I just had a
podcast where I would I would just is
called open tabs and I just open tabs on
my computer on my Safari browser yeah
throughout the weekend then I bring my
computer in on Wednesday and then I just
go through and click out through the
tabs and I found very quick that my
views on a lot of things are super
ignorant and I would get lit up you ever
gotten like in trouble trouble no no but
I've been chastised on like NPR type
shows like where they just like they're
like why do you say this and then I'm
like oh no hi I got drunk and they're
like yeah but it sounds like you
represent this I'm like I don't and
they're like well they better understand
what you're saying is into the ears of
you know five hundred thousand people
and that's what it's sounding like and I
was like but that's not what I mean and
they're like well that's what you say so
I listen no I don't mean it
I've had I've said horrible stuff to
where I don't even know what I said I
mean I thought it was a joke and then
like okay okay and so uh oh you gonna
leave the door open like my daughters
are you afraid of spiders too I said I
said something one time a bunch of fans
just DM me like can we get audio on that
by the way women pee like they sound
like they have a prostate problem I take
it back that's just no miner come out in
the mist like you can tell the size of
man's dick based on how loud he pees
I've always believed that I then and
I've been a member I took a piss next to
Will Smith and I pushed so hard if I
almost shit my pants Owen want him to
think I had a small dick you can go
ahead and wipe I'm not looking yeah
front scoop and apparently go sidesaddle
too she's the like she's riding a three
wheeler here what we gonna say Brenton
hey daddy right did I say your name
wrong Benten fucking you know who I'm
thinking of bread and biddle comb yeah
yeah sanctions I never wash my hands I
did not wash my hands after peeing
that's the least of our worries right
now is if I hand sanitizing my hands in
the morning on a flight I want to throw
up why because it feels like someone
drinking alcohol I don't want is it oh
is it true that when guys land on planes
they get erections no really no one has
had that I've never had an erection on a
plane really never never you never
jerked off in an airplane bathroom never
never never never never panic when I
wasn't
during summer October I thought what if
I just jerked off but that get my mind
off this fucking turbulence the the I
had to I had I had a manager at a comedy
club one time tell me he comes in I just
had Georgia and he shuts the door and
he's like amen
Congrats on the bait or I was I was
about to have Georgia I was about to
have George died like two weeks out he's
like hey congrats is she close I said
yeah we're inducing in two weeks and
he's like alright cool because there's a
lot of stuff that people won't tell you
like dad stuff they don't want to talk
about I said really and he's like yeah
yeah yeah like they're like the first
time you hold your kid all your dicks
gonna get hard yeah I was like okay he's
totally natural haves all of us but I
just give me a heads up I was like all
right and I was panicked that first time
they're like don't hold your daughter
I'm like I'm in sweatpants I'm okay
and then I did hold her and my dick
didn't get hard and I was like what's
wrong with me I got my dicks not getting
hard and so the whole first time not
cute enough but no I was like yeah that
definitely and then and then I said that
to another dad and they're like no your
dad you definitely your dicks not
supposed to get hard and I was like for
real and they're like yeah I don't know
what that guy told me why that guy told
you that he also told me he's like we're
having a hard time keeping the grit and
getting the girls to sleep in their own
room and he goes oh super-easy flip the
doorknob around lock him in the room and
I was like sound like what was your
health care provider at the time was
your health by the way who it is after
the show and you're gonna go who it is I
take my friend Robbie Anderson who's the
funniest dude he's a showrunner like
does um tons of stuff and he after he
had his daughter like three months and I
was like Astor daughter and he goes it's
just like she's fine but she's got this
like thing inside her butthole that is
like a really big problem and I've just
I found it and and we're trying to
figure what to do about it and I was
like oh my god that's awful and did it
up and he did this for like days where
he's like yeah just like every time I
check it like there's still a growth
right inside her butthole and I was like
wow this sounds awful and he's like
idiot I've never put my finger and my
daughter's butthole before this is not
real good I was like I was like oh my
god what happened he's like well I just
felt it one day that's so funny I was
told a story by a writer
I'll tell you his name write his name
down okay you might know this guy yeah
yeah okay yes I do know him he told me
we were meeting I was at a development
deal and they were setting me up with
Ryder meetings we meet at a bar and he
says um he goes I said something you
have kids and he goes yeah I just had a
kid I was like really and he's like yeah
it's kind of crazy cuz he was born
without a butthole I was like really and
he's again so every day I've got a we've
got to create a butthole so we've been
we have to put a rod up his ass or this
makeshift asshole that we're making and
I'm like and I don't know if he was
fighting with me but I have thought
about that story for now 18 years I
think he never at any point never broke
and he was like so what do you want to
do is to come about and I was like and I
swear to God I know is I know his wife
and I wanted to and I wanted to ask his
wife by it so it's a weird thing to ask
and and I don't even know if it's
physically possible people there was a
thing I saw and maybe it's just my
algorithm but I had a news story come up
the other day of this woman who's
talking about not having a vagina and I
didn't even want to click on it I just
wonder I've always wondered if he was
just fucking with me at the beginning of
this maybe and then he was like and then
he like killed his drinking it's a weird
bit to not then come back but he's got
the sense of humor where it would be
something that would make it there's
certain people all they want to do is
make of themselves laugh it's like a
weird
I'm sadistic like yeah doesn't like
pranks I've never understood that I'm
not good at a price I hate very they
make me uncomfortable they make me
cringe I don't like it I've never like
tried it I could never hold it long
enough I feel too bad for the other
person I'd you know honked I mean I did
this shit prank show I don't like movies
where where you know that someone's like
lying in there an undercover agent get
caught it makes me anxious and you don't
watch it I'm gonna like you the guy at
like magic shows as a kid we're like you
know oh so you are a big part of why I
do a podcast you gave me some really
good advice what did I say I don't
remember but something helpful I when
you said you wanted to do a podcast I
was like oh you're fucking dialed in for
the looks you're the right person to do
a podcast I asked you Chris and who was
the other person Jim not Jim Jeffries
who was the other person that was
helpful to me Oh Andrew
and and you were like don't overthink it
don't try to be funny and don't book the
big guests in the beginning remember I
told and don't promote it just get good
at it don't promote it at least so man
I'm telling you it's it's the white guys
guide to comedy is just suck when no one
knows you suck mm-hmm and then get
better and then all of a sudden one day
people find you hmm and then they're
like oh shit this is fucking amazing
yeah and I mean my podcast was
unlistenable I mean I did a podcast with
Joey inaudible inaudible that's what I
know what I want to be it was unhear
Obul I couldn't even hear Belen it was
meant for the deaf and anyway he yep
yeah so but I did a podcast with Ralphie
and Joey and at one point they both fell
asleep at the same time and you can just
hear them out sleep apnea each other and
it was me and it's just going like I
can't believe I'm still here it's just
me guys one of them opening I would say
something in Georgia like now the pie
guys are such a big thing I want to go
back to very early birth very early
rogen before anyone was really listening
I just said to someone the other day we
were talking about Rogan maybe I maybe I
mean Rogan like two Studios ago when
there's like a brick wall behind him
there's like a purple light under um his
podcast well I mean his podcast is a
blast to do every time I've done and do
it I will say that when we started it
not I didn't start it I was just I was
just I was early on the podcast
it was so fuck you would just giggle
just fuck around because my back then
it's like you know it doesn't seem like
you guys understood how big it was gonna
get and there were no stakes yeah we
would trash comics we would trash
Booker's we would trash clubs we would
just get high and then it was like it
was almost like you just burned down a
building to just walk away and go I was
fucking fun I mean it was so fun and by
the way it's still a blast to do only
really
I'm doing it next week I mean thought it
would just Joe in a while but it's I
think it's because he's got such little
time to put comic song because he's got
such big guests he has a little bigger
of a responsibility than he did back
then yeah I remember watching him like
presidential candidates since pandemic
epidemiologist it's my favorite podcast
to listen to and I definitely don't want
to just hear episodes with myself and
Ari and Tommy and Joe they're great
they're always great yeah but the people
he has one now are fucking I mean smiley
and I think he also doesn't I mean he's
still from what I understand like has
huge people that want to come on and
he's kind of like I don't know them you
know like he's even picky I reached out
to him like a month before my podcast or
before my special was airing I was like
hey my specials there and Saint Patty's
Day is there anyway I hop on the podcast
and you know Joe would bend over fucking
backwards for any of us yeah him and
he's like eh okay here the dates I got
and you just like and you know he's
podcasting every single day and also
trying to be the dad of a family and
sand up an ass so he's just over he's
over a book and but those early days or
just I mean they're you know it was the
funnest like I want to go back and
listen to those before it was fucking a
hundred million listeners it was just so
irresponsible it was and then Brian was
so distracting he was so distracting
that you'd have a podcast a mirror I
didn't ever doing a podcast with Joe and
Brian where they just bought the entire
time and I was just sat watch them for
like because I even like I was so
integral to that podcast was so
distracting from its fucking direction
he would just he they'd have someone
really smart on in Mario Doody puddles
at Olive Garden there's there's if you
want to laugh hard there's a o'brien is
these compilations of Brian D railing
interesting conversations as a fan of
the show it was like we have eight weeks
of content that people are going to go
watch old Rogen episodes old when I
started doing them when we tell you what
like I wasn't doing him by himself
you just get high with him mm-hmm I
can't get high and do that Joe Rogan I
one time I went on and I was like okay I
think this before I understood how big
the show was also Oh
Niger's I didn't know like the first
couple times I did it and then I walked
down the street people with a clever
gone rogue and I was like geez oh yeah I
just didn't understand how big it was
and then I was like okay now I know how
big it is let me be careful and then I
wanted to so he's like you want to smoke
a joint I was like fuck and I was like
maybe this will help me relax and thank
God
Joe can talk himself for three hours
about anything intelligently cuz it was
clear that I was so high I just kind of
sat there and I on that show I've been
so fucking high I got high one time all
I know is we got into a conversation of
if you could throw fish in the air and
they would start flying at 10 feet would
there be any fish left and like if you
could catch a fish and then threw it in
the air and it would just fly away all
anyone do all day was catch fish and
just throw him it and we could not stop
laughing we did a five-hour fucking pot
did you know Joe when he had piranhas no
I've only known Joe for probably like 10
years huh I met I was a fan of Joe's way
before I was a friend of Joe's that's
interesting when I came into the comedy
store he had just left cuz of them and
see a thing so I like had heard of Joe
and the world I met him then I didn't
know him yet but there was this
interesting like albatross at the store
cuz he had left and like the vibe I got
I came at I gotta be honest with you I
will say one of the luckier things in my
life is getting to have known comics
before they are where they're yeah yeah
bill burr I've known bill for probably
20 years I've known Joe for 10 but I met
you couldn't meet bill today and become
best friends with him no I remember
someone told me a story the other day
where they said Bill came up and the guy
is like good to meet you and Bill goes
we've met and the guy goes no I don't
think the a veneers no no we definitely
have and he was like no we definitely
haven't he was like are you sure and
he's like yeah I'm sure I'm bill goes
playing should have gone with the buddy
and walked away can I tell you of all
the guests we've have on I don't tell
people who the guest is anymore
before hand what do you mean I like I
used to go like this is the guest coming
on the show this weekend like the day it
comes out you'll know the guess it's on
there'll be clips of you and really oh
yeah I don't say like Bert's coming on
next one say do you have any questions
for him oh yeah I don't do that anymore
I kind of just like surprising and when
I
I used to when I was sort of like
figuring out experimenting how to do the
show I'd go like billboards coming on
Jim Jefferies coming on Davis girl
coming on what are your questions and I
would take questions and when I said
bill was coming on people were like I
don't know this good idea you got to be
careful bill burr is we talked about on
bill Bert he is notoriously like a rough
interview and I said well I don't
understand why because I didn't I saw
your own Bert bill that was a great
podcast but like Bill and Theo I thought
was a bat a fine podcast too same with
h3h3 I didn't have a problem in any of
those podcast people are like fringe
this was brutal to watch I was like I
don't I don't see it i bill is just bill
is a bill is a he's first of all he's a
he's a contrarian yes and he's playing
devil's advocate always to be playful
that's how his mind works the same with
Joe you'll say something to Joe and Joe
will go why did you say that well what
do you think about this it's really just
exploratory you know and also just be
ready to defend your point and Bill it's
it's an and Bill it gets comfortable in
discomfort disagreeing with people
doesn't make him uncomfortable I also
think that bill like all great comics do
not like to be lauded for being like
great comics doesn't like the adulation
that's when he shuts down it seems like
if you tell him he's one of the best he
just he's like nah come on in yeah just
what are we doing I guess let's talk
let's not do that let's just talk in
hangout anything but I love Bill I think
yeah Bill's one of my one of my favorite
human beings but getting to know Bill
and Joe at before mm-hmm
they like getting to know Joe getting
there Joe and Joe was by the way very
very famous at the time yeah who isn't
where he was today and you just do the
podcast and you'd hang out for another
hour and just bullshit and gossip and
it's like it's I'm lucky that I still
have that relationship with the more you
can hang with him you don't have to like
you don't have to like Joe also refuses
to be as famous as he is like he still
wants to be a comic like he's like
people come up to me he's like hey I'm
at like he'll just it feels like I don't
know I just feels like he's gotten so
famous in the last couple years and he's
kind of trying to just stay Joe himself
it's I think I think you're right I
think he's trying to I don't know I
can't imagine what's his life's like I
can't imagine
but I know what my life's like and it's
nothing like his and I know how busy I
am and I know how frazzled I get and I
know how it can be frustrating to go out
in public and and and you know but
there's also a difference between being
famous and people knowing you because
they've seen you on TV and then being
someone's like religious leader like
Joe's like a religion now it feels like
you know I think there's a lot of guys
that I know for a fact in just and I can
only speak from my experience but in
just that sober October that we do or
the weight loss challenge Tom and I did
yeah there's a lot of guys that
connected with that there are bigger
guys that felt lost and maybe didn't
have so much of a father figure or or a
figure in their life to give them advice
or they could draw advice from or draw
inspiration from and I'll tell you
there's a responsibility I feel and I
would have never felt it had I not be
friends with Joe because Joe kind of it
sells it like him and you just can't
fuck around with this like you gotta
like just you know be the guy you say
you gonna be and and yeah and be
thoughtful of your words and and Joe is
very honorable that way yeah it's all
about honor I'll tell you him and burr
or better guys than me
I'm gonna make you keep talking to us
until your wife as she said honking
outside 6:25 said I'll be there in 15
okay all right I'll just say let
yourself in
so what's your site Tom Segura com yeah
let's promote your Rogen appearance help
me I'm Rogan next week I feel like
that's at this point I went on foul and
the other night and they're like what
are you promoting I was like I think my
podcast appearances like well just
promoting each other at this point I you
know I was I was pretty specific about
what podcast I wanted to do what I'm
gonna promote this special says also
thought I was gonna do television that's
all gone away there's no there's no
flights to New York that I'm gonna take
there's no run let me ask you something
I'm gonna just be burn a couple bridges
real quick okay if you could if you only
could do three things yeah you were and
sometimes you can only cuz you can't
follow a lot of people don't know if you
do Fallon you can't do Colbert if you do
Kim well you can't do Fallon like you
it's like called if you can't follow
right you do Ellen then you can't do
Rachael Ray or whatever I think those
rules are changing a little bit
in terms of bang for your buck and I Bob
this is gonna this is gonna there's
gonna burn bridges doing fighter in the
kid tomorrow but I know the question is
the question is you can only do three
podcast and talk shows
okay well first of all you don't have
concentric circles right is that that
overlap no I'm just asking the most
eyeballs so okay if and this isn't Bert
this is my advice to any comic you
definitely you come to LA you do Rogen
okay mmm-hmm you go to New York and you
do I'm including Fallon Colbert I know
I'm doing three podcast first I'm saying
that's you oh you can only do three
media outlets oh wow podcast and
late-night okay cuz that's my point
are our late-night shows even going to
break the top three I don't think pop
you have three you can do three press
things Wow yeah I don't know III I would
always do Conan cuz he lets you go for
longer and you have more chance of
getting a viral clip his podcast no I do
his talk show
okay I'd always do Rogen I think he has
more reach than anyone to the last one I
would do I'm gonna throw Ellen out there
oh oh yeah I actually not only would I
throw out Ellen I would throw out Kelly
Clarkson's show her numbers are very big
I'm definitely not getting on Kelly
Clarkson's and I'm not also not getting
on Ellen's I was like I tried my last
special a hard push to get on Ellen and
they're just say it's not it's not right
for audience because I look like I look
and I take my shirt off and they're like
more hard pass but I love Ellen I think
Ellen's fucking awesome I loved her
sitcom when she did when she came out I
laughed
yeah out loud at the airport mr. right
mr. wrong yes straight he's like I would
break my finger for you she goes please
don't please don't he just goes Punk
I was crying laughs I remember one of my
favorite like before I really understood
what a joke even was like I was like
trying to figure it together by watching
TV shows she did an episode
her show and it took place in a coffee
shop and friends just happened and
friends got huge so she would make jokes
about friends in her show she would be
like someone would come in and be like
you know what I actually don't know
that's fucking brilliant she'd go like
oh we're gonna go over to Central Perk
within her show she would be doing digs
on friends but there was an episode
which Union Garofalo huge huge swings I
mean wrong so Janeane Garofalo comes I
love her tattoos she makes me want to
get tattoos all over me so Janeane
Garofalo comes in and it was such a
great story the story was that she was
basically trying to be friends with
Janeane Garofalo and this is before we
knew she was gay so there was obviously
all kinds of other subtext if you go
back and watch it now yeah but so she's
like trying to like make Janeane
Garofalo her friend and she offers her a
croissant and she goes would you like a
croissant and Janeane goes no thanks and
she just went what about now dumb and
surprising and just such a great like
well simple clean perfect sitcom Joe
yeah I love Ellen love did you know that
in China Ellen's show is called dancing
lady no it's not heartbreaking I'm
loving these texts that we're getting
what are they saying all the texts from
comedians Wow
what what Marc Maron's coming on next
week you have any advice for me oh I
don't know this I'm not by the way I
can't read these fucking texts what from
your from your wife or from comic no no
I haven't got one firmly in yeah I'm
getting many text messages you get them
from Rogen I'm getting I'm on a chain
but the broke and I haven't heard from
today but it's my earring from Rogen a
lot and Rogen's one that scares me
well Rogen's podcasts with that guy is i
think what made people start shutting
shit down that's the first time we oh
that's the first time we started taking
it seriously because the guy was like
this is not a fucking joke and this is
gonna go into the fall oh and and it's
airborne which is important because
washing your hands is I just all I can
think is I'm just gonna fucking hole up
in my house take xanax and that's it do
you do xanax before you go to bed no I
do one I'll do one some
I'll do one like it like four o'clock so
that I don't drink that night I'm
texting things I'm worried that she's
outside and she might fool us do you
want to check and just make sure Benton
um i-i'll take one of four clocks it I
won't drink if I take one and I only
take a quarter of a milligram which is
an X which isn't a lot but if I take a
quarter of a milligram I am a guarantee
not to drink and I and I'm no you know
do before shows I would never do I would
never be able to think on a xanax
yeah which is why I take is it is not
good we should do as a next pod dude
where we have so much time to pod yeah
this is all we got
yeah let's annex pop I'm telling you I
think I got a UH my only fear is that I
do my podcast out of my house so
bringing people in that I don't like I
don't want to bring the infected in you
know I'm not infected no look I can
overthink this and I could definitely
over talk this and I don't know anything
so don't listen to me all I know is I
will reschedule every show I will do
every show look I love touring I'm gonna
tour until the day's end and if and if
our comedy economy goes in the shitter
and we need to lower ticket prices to
make sure people do that I probably
won't do that but where are your
rescheduled days because they're not on
your it comes from Maine feeling yeah
Thursday June 11th in Peoria Illinois
Friday June 12th Rockford Milwaukee Ben
Green Bay on the 14th June 25th I will
be coming back to New Orleans
June 25th with just ball sweat and ball
sweat and ball Montgomery Alabama the
following day Huntsville two shows
Saturday June 27th and then Sioux City
June 30th Cedar Rapids
June July July 30th July 31st August
first Springfield Missouri and August
seventh second st. Louis which by the
way it's wild that we're touring in July
in August it's not often that we would
do August
I'm Sacramento I'm coming July 24th is
the rescheduled date which is so crazy
san francisco's July 25th two shows oh
that's what's happening and then July
31st is the Royal Oak reschedule
August first Indianapolis August 7th
Houston August 8th Chicago Illinois the
two shows Vic two shows that night what
it's a fucking rockin venue that I love
look we're very lucky to be able to
perform in these gorgeous venues and I
don't I mean obviously I don't want to
just deplete my fan base by them all
dying wants to kill you guys why you
stay alive to buy merch I wanna be
fuckin 60 years old I want this is my
goal I'm saying this to my fans right
now my goal is that we all continue
drinking together and so I want to be 65
I want to be on a fucking cruise ship I
want to do this like once here and then
and it's just I want to be doing Collis
if the work shows at the Staples Center
with by the way fuck fluffy and Joe
Coyte we're gonna do the fucking call in
sick to work so fucking I want to keep
having fun and partying I have a
question can't we do it with just 50
people
oh no no because we have 15 on the show
very lucky people I want to do this I
want to do this um oh I was saying maybe
we do like a live stream I'm put up a go
foot go fund me and have people call in
and you know do it like we did the end
of the world show have bur me you Rogen
and I think we need to start going
things to give proceeds to service
people at these venues in these
festivals because it's like what went on
in South by Southwest is just
devastating the amount of people that
lost money the artists of course but the
service people and the the tech people
and all I can say is I leaned down on my
podcasts
I understand look I'm at home to with my
kids I'm gonna get on the treadmill you
think I'm gonna want to like there's
nothing it seems like the worst part
about all this is the people have to
spend time with their children oh my god
school just canceled for three months
magnitude don't you want to see her
we're taking my daughter's for drive
we're driving on the 405 right now
Podcast I got bill Bert I've got two
bears one cave I've got the Bert cast
I'm doing Rogen next week like I'm like
I love Park yes special hey big boy
start streaming Tuesday providing a line
there's lots of content that you must
have out there up something's burning oh
she's here your wife is here all right
Bert Kreischer yes 100% I feel like the
last time I did your progress I wasn't
that good uh that's something I carry
with me I'll tell you with Lia I'll tell
you later what nothing
what no way
we walked out and me and you were still
laughing and you I think you hung out
with the dogs and we all sat in the
front yard for a second and Lee and you
walked away in the ENGOs we were working
on a sitcom still we're gonna succumb
and she goes Whitney has to play your
wife no one really she goes a hundred
percent you guys have such good
chemistry and I was like okay she was
like definitely and I was like I'm not
even gonna do the scene where you shaved
my pussy in the sitcom won't even do the
scene won't even pretend you yeah you
will be a robot Bert Kreischer shows
reschedule we love you love you too
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]